Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 177 und mein Versprechen wieder mehr Technik zu machen, folge ich hier auch gleich mit dieser Ausgabe und war dafür auch mal wieder etwas unterwegs. Sitze hier jetzt in Frankfurt am Main, in einem Hotelzimmerchen und mit mir ist Michael Steil. Hallo. Hallo. Ja, hier habe ich dich abfangen können, auf der Durchreise sozusagen.
In einem wahnsinnig kleinen Hotelzimmerchen.
Genau, wir hatten uns quasi auf dem letzten Kongress schon verabredet, das auch irgendwie mal hinzubekommen.
Die Funklochgötter waren nicht auf unserer Seite.
Die Funklochgötter?
Ja, du wolltest mich doch erreichen, aber dann war ich wahrscheinlich unten.
Ja, auf dem Kongresstermine und Treffen einzuhalten, das ist irgendwie unmöglich. Aber es ist eigentlich auch unmöglich, während der Kongresszeit irgendwelche längeren Radiosendungen aufzunehmen, wo man sich konzentrieren muss. Von daher ist es glaube ich auch besser so. Naja, auf jeden Fall ein Grund, wieder zu reisen für den Express, im Express zu sitzen. Und das Thema, um das es heute gehen soll, ist der Commodore 64. Denn das ist ja einerseits Teil deiner Kulturgeschichte, kann man so sagen. Und das ist das eigentliche Experiment, auch Teil meiner Kulturgeschichte. Eigentlich ist es ja so, ich kann ja eigentlich nur Sendungen machen, die gut werden, wenn ich selber so recht keinen Plan von der Sache habe, weil das ja eigentlich hier nur so ein Fortbildungsprogramm ist von mir, wo ich auf Record drücke und alle daran teilhaben lasse. Und nun begab es sich natürlich so, dass ich auch mit dieser Kiste sozialisiert wurde und so allerlei Einblick gewonnen habe, wie das ist, wenn man so ganz jung ist und an die Maschinerinnen gelassen wird. Aber du bist ja dann sozusagen die zweite Generation.
Genau, du bist eigentlich von einer ganz anderen Seite hier. Du bist erste Generation, die 84 wahrscheinlich geklickt hat, 83, 84, 85, vielleicht 86 dann weggeschmissen, Amiga gekauft.
Ich habe mir einen ST gekauft, weil Amiga kam irgendwie nicht am Start. Das war einer der schlechtesten Computerkäufern, die ich je gemacht habe.
Okay, hatte ich nie, kenne ich auch nur von der Theorie. Ja, und bei mir dann zweite Generation, ich habe ihn erst 89 gekriegt. Da waren sie eigentlich schon dabei, den zu verramschen, aber sie haben ihn bis 94 noch hergestellt, hauptsächlich weil Ostblock offen war. Da haben sie ja einen Haufen den Ostblock noch verkauft und deswegen war das alles noch auf dem Markt, bis dann Commodore untergegangen ist.
Du bist jetzt sicher auf dem Ostblock?
Nein, aber ich bin halt aus der Ramsch-Generation, wo er richtig billig wurde. Ich habe ihn für 100 Mark damals gekriegt, neu. Da haben sie ja Super Game 64, Spielekonsole positioniert, in so einer Kiste mit dem Fußballer drauf.
1400 Mark habe ich bezahlt.
Ich musste ja auch einen Floppy-Laufwerke kaufen, das kostet 250. Ich habe mir meine Eltern lange nicht gekauft.
Absurd. Na ja, wer es noch nicht begriffen hat, die Rede ist natürlich von dem Homecomputer-Modell, was gemeinhin als das erfolgreichste Homecomputer-Gerät aller Zeiten bezeichnet wird. Ich weiß nicht genau, stimmt das eigentlich?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Da war auf AskTechnica vor kurzem mal so ein Artikel mit Market-Share von den unterschiedlichen Computern zur unterschiedlichen Zeit und wenn man irgendwie ab 1986 oder so was schaut, dann sind natürlich die IBM-Kompatiblen da schon weit über 50 Prozent und die anderen haben keine Bedeutung mehr. Aber also die Daten von da waren auch nicht perfekt. Da sind auch einige Hunde drin in der Datenbank, was die da zusammen gesammelt haben. Aber 1984 zum Beispiel war er der meistverkaufte, das stimmt wahrscheinlich, und der hat es wirklich geschafft. Also die Zahl, die jetzt gesichert ist, ist mindestens mal 12 Millionen, haben sie verkauft innerhalb von diesen zwölf Jahren. Und ich glaube, zusammengerechnet sind 728 noch dazu, dann kommt man auf 17. Und da wüsste ich nicht, was da ähnlich viel haben könnte. Ich meine, wenn man natürlich Nintendo oder so was dazuzählt, die haben mehr, klar. Aber ich meine, die Amigas haben sie nur auf ein paar Millionen gebracht, die SDs vielleicht auf eine. Das waren ja ganz andere Zahlen damals. Ich meine, wie viel iPhones und Xbox und Playstation werden heutzutage verkauft.
Das geht heutzutage in einem Quartal weg, ganz klar.
Aber für damalige Zeiten sind das schon gigantische Zahlen.
Es war ja auch für damalige Zeiten eine gigantische Maschine. Also diese Homecomputer-Zeit, die hat ja eigentlich auch erst zu Anfang der 80er-Jahre wirklich begonnen. Es gab so frühe Bewegungen, Sinclair, also das war auch noch eine Zeit, da gab es so eine Vielfalt von Maschinen und eine Vielfalt von Konzepten auch. Bau- und Formfaktoren und Prozessoren, die verwendet wurden und verschiedenen Herangehensweisen an dieser Herausforderung, einen Computer zu bauen, der eben für das Home, damals sozusagen Familie, Kinder, Jugendliche, was weiß ich, die Familie attraktiv waren. Und da gibt es ja eine ganze Menge Vorreiter von allen möglichen Technologien, die damals eine Rolle gespielt haben. Also Amstrad zum Beispiel in Deutschland, dann später unter dem Namen Schneider besser bekannt, weil Schneider, also die Bude, die eher so durch Musik-Tower und Fernseher usw. bekannt wurde, die haben das dann halt so in der Fittiche genommen. Deswegen kennt den Namen Amstrad eigentlich keiner so recht. Oder na, Sinclair halt.
Die sind jetzt alle von der Z80 Seite, also von der CPU. Im Grunde die zwei großen Cams, die Z80 CPUs und die 65002 basierten CPUs. Und Schneider, Sinclair, das hatten alle Z80.
Also 1989 bist du an den ersten C460 gekommen, da war das ja für mich schon volle Vergangenheit.
Gut, mein Geldbeutel war natürlich auch anders als deiner zu der Zeit, oder?
Bei mir war es halt wirklich so Taschengeld und Weihnachten und was man halt so konnte. Na ja, klar, da war ich schon im Usenet unterwegs. Na ja gut, hier geht es ja nicht um mich, sondern es geht hier um diese Maschine, weil warum reden wir jetzt überhaupt über so ein altes Gerät? Ich meine, was macht denn für dich den Reiz aus?
Genau, warum sitze ich immer noch an so einer Kiste? Moment, was heißt an so einer Kiste? Aber warum beschäftige ich mich noch damit? Warum beschäftigen sich noch so viele Leute damit?
Also, dass ich ja nicht nur 89 schon noch damit beschäftige, sondern du wirst es ja auch immer noch. Wir sitzen hier, es liegen zwei C64 Mainboards vor uns. Das eine ist Revision C.
Nein, nein, nein, du musst die komplette ACI-NOO, das ist die Hauptversion und dann noch die Revision davon.
Okay, und was sagt mir das dann? Hier steht 250407.
Und Revision C, genau, und der hier ist ein 250469, Revision 4. Also es sind ja auch zwei ganz unterschiedliche Boards. Also sie haben 16 unterschiedliche Boards rausgegeben, immer mal wieder kleine Änderungen gemacht. Einmal das Board komplett neu designt, lauter kleinere Chips, neuere Chips, um das noch billiger zu machen. Also das war ihnen immer sehr wichtig, dass sie das Ding so billig herstellen, wie es noch gerade geht. Und ihnen gehörte ja auch die Chip-Fabrik. Die ganzen Chips waren ja, es war alles inhouse. Das ist ja so ähnlich wie Apple das heutzutage macht. Deswegen konnten die halt auch unglaublich gute Preise haben oder sehr gute Computer halt zu einem akzeptablen Preis.
Also meinst du, mit inhouse, es wurde alles inhouse entwickelt? Also alle Chips wurden selber entwickelt?
Nicht nur entwickelt, sondern auch produziert. Also die Chip-Fabriken gehörten ihnen auch. Und andersherum Apple und Atari und alle anderen und Nintendo. Nein, Nintendo nicht, aber Apple und Atari, die mussten wirklich von Commodore auch die Chips kaufen. Denn der 65002, das Design, das gehörte ihnen halt.
Gehörte wem? Ach ja, richtig, stimmt.
Die hatten das 76 oder so was, 77 haben sie MOS gekauft.
Genau, also MOS war der damalige Prozessorenhersteller und der gehörte dann Commodore. Insofern war das für sie natürlich die naheliegende Technologie, die zu verwenden.
Und die hatten auch die guten Leute, die dann die anderen Chips bauen konnten. Also erstmal hatten sie schon eine gute Bibliothek an IOU-Controllern und so Zeug, wo man sich schon mal eine Computer zusammenschrauben kann. Da haben sie die Pads dann draus gemacht, die konnten nicht viel. Aber dann haben sie mal eigene gute, so einen Videocontroller, einen Sound-Controller und so weiter entwickelt und das ging dann so in Richtung C64.
So, aber jetzt hatte ich ja eigentlich gerade eine andere Frage gestellt, nämlich was macht den Reiz aus? Warum dieses Gerät?
Weil das, glaube ich, ein sehr gutes Beispiel dafür ist für ein Gerät, das man wirklich mal verstehen kann. Also es ist ungeheuer komplex eigentlich, also man kann wirklich sehr, sehr lange da forschen und es ist, na gut, wirklich verstehen auch nicht, weil da gibt es auch noch sehr viele Fragen, die ich habe und deswegen interessiert es mich eben auch weiter zu forschen. Also ich gehe weniger von der, ich will was dafür produzieren, Seite ran, sondern mehr, ich will noch mehr verstehen, was da dann eigentlich wirklich vorgeht. Und wenn man sich heutzutage Systeme anschaut, da gibt es ja überhaupt keine Einstiegsmöglichkeit, wie man sich damit beschäftigen kann, dass man wirklich was damit lernt, wie das jetzt funktioniert. Also ich bin ja eher von der Software-Seite her, bin Assembler-Hacker, aber so eine Maschine schafft es auch für einen, dass man noch eine Ebene runtergeht und sich mal wirklich auf dem Mainboard noch die Traces anschaut und der Chip ist mit dem verbunden und so weiter. Wie funktioniert da die Bus-Codierung? Es ist hackbar. Es ist wirklich so ein super Prototypen-Hack-Device.
Massig verfügbar. Man kann auch mal ein paar kaputt machen.
Genau, bei IWELL 20 Euro so was momentan. Halt nur das Gerät und teilweise auch mit dem Diskettenlaufwerk dazu. Und es ist, und es erinnert eben auch an die gute alte Zeit, wo man noch wirklich Zyklen gezählt hat, wo man ganz genau wusste, was da in der Maschine vorgegangen ist. So eine Optimierung, die man heutzutage halt nicht macht. Da bastelt man sich was in PHP zusammen oder in Python oder sowas und dann läuft, passt.
Und hat eigentlich auch keine Vorstellung von Performance und Latenzen etc.
Genau, die Performance eben von irgendwas, was ich auf dem C64 laufen lassen kann, das kann ich halt auf die Mikrosekunde genau ausrechnen. Wenn ich mir das auf Papier hinschreibe, dann kann ich daneben immer hinschreiben, wie viel Taktzyklen. Und das muss ich teilweise auch, wenn ich so Advanced Techniken machen will.
Kann ich mich auch noch ganz gut dran erinnern. Das war ja auch alles noch so, das Ding ist mit einem Megahertz getaktet, beziehungsweise genau ist es glaube ich etwas weniger gewesen.
Kommt darauf an, ob du PAL oder NTSC hast. Weil es ist gebundelt mit der Frequenz, mit der der Videocontroller die Pixel raushaut. Und deswegen läuft der PAL mit 985 Kilohertz ungefähr und der NTSC glaube ich mit irgendwie 1.002 Kilohertz.
Das heißt, die US-Variante war schneller. Und das Timing war dann sozusagen bei den Programmen auch ganz anders.
Ja, das war echt ein Problem damals. Man konnte die Spiele nicht einfach importieren. Also anfangs schon, weil die Spiele nicht so geschrieben waren, dass sie so timing-kritisch waren. Aber später die ganzen Demos, die liefen einfach auf der anderen Maschine nicht.
Also ich muss auch sagen, das ist jetzt auch wirklich der Aspekt. Also diese Möglichkeit, das System so vollständig wie möglich zu verstehen. Und ich meine, da kann man so viel daraus ziehen. Also ich meine, wenn man so ein altes Gerät versteht, dann versteht man auf einmal auch so viel von dem heutigen. Es hat sich zwar alles weiterentwickelt und es ist alles schneller, höher, weiter. Aber im Prinzip sind die Grundlehren, die man daraus ziehen kann, auch heute noch gültig. Das hat sich halt alles vervielfacht in Geschwindigkeit und Komplexität. Aber man hat da immer noch eine CPU, man hat da immer noch Datenbusse, immer noch IO und man hat immer noch...
Die Assembler-Programmierung funktioniert im Grunde auch noch so. Da hast du Register, du musst immer explizit aus dem Speicher lesen. Wenn ein Reset passiert, dann muss irgendwie ein ROM reinspringen. Das ROM muss irgendwie reingemapt sein. Wenn ich mehr von diesen Chips habe, als ich eigentlich Adressleitungen habe, als ich ansprechen kann, dann muss man zwischen Chips hin und her schalten, muss man dann Banking machen und so weiter. Das gibt es alles heute auch noch so.
Dann versuchen wir das Thema mal so ein bisschen so aufzuziehen, um vielleicht jemanden, der keine Ahnung von Computern hat, aber für den auch die Systemarchitektur als solche immer noch so ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln ist. Woraus besteht der C64? Was macht das Maschinen aus?
Das kann man eigentlich ein bisschen von der geschichtlichen Seite her sehen. Also der MOS 6502, dieser Chip, der da zentral drin ist und um den, also das ist halt wirklich der zentrale Chip und das macht sehr viel von der Persönlichkeit von der Maschine aus. 1975 wurde der entwickelt und dann auch der Atari und die alten Apples und so weiter und auch das NES hatten den. Und damals, als der rauskam, hatten die so ein Evaluation Board bei MOS gebaut, das wirklich nur aus dem Chip bestand und ROM und einem kleinen IOU-Controller. Das heißt, man stellt sich das jetzt so vor, man hat ein Board, man steckt da drauf ein 650.02, man steckt RAM-Leitungen dazu und dann verbindet man ganz einfach die Adressleitungen von RAM und der CPU und zudem dann auch noch zum ROM dazu. Man hängt das alles einfach zusammen, das ist im Endeffekt einfach nur wirklich geradlinig die Leitung.
Also, RAM, Schreiblesespeicher, wo man irgendwie abspeichern kann, ROM, wo irgendwie ein Programm drin steht, aber das kann man nur auslesen.
Genau. Also ein bisschen ROM braucht man immer, selbst wenn man seinen eigenen Code ausführen will, weil man schaltet ein und ja, wo soll denn der Programmcode herkommen?
Das ist sozusagen das BIOS.
Ja, was kein guter Begriff ist.
Na gut, aber das, was so gestartet wird, eigentlich ist Firmware der richtige Begriff dafür. Ja, okay, gut. Also aber das, was gestartet wird, bevor das eigentliche Betriebssystem übernehmen kann oder was auch immer man selber so an Code hat, was man einfach erstmal so tun muss, um überhaupt auch die einzelnen Komponenten zu initialisieren und zum Leben zu erwecken.
Ja, oder vielleicht initialisiert man noch nicht mal, sondern man ist wirklich nur ein winziger Bootloader, der irgendwie auf einem Bus wartet oder auf irgendeinem eigenen Ausgabebarstein wartet, dass jemand was macht und da irgendwie was drüber schiebt.
Und was war jetzt mit diesem Evaluation Board?
Also der hieß Kim, Kim One.
Ach, der Kim.
Der Kim, genau.
Das war dieses, okay, alles klar.
Genau.
Der hatte auch noch so, hatte nicht auch noch so DIP-Schalter?
Der hatte so eine Hex-Tastatur drauf. Das heißt, da war ein kleines ROM, ich glaube, das war 512-Bytes oder so was. Und da war wirklich noch ein ganz kleiner Code darauf, da konnte man dann über dieses Hex-Board quasi auf den Speicher zugreifen, konnte was lesen, was schreiben und dann sagen, ich will jetzt das ausführen. Und so konnte man halt mit dieser 65002-CPU mal ein bisschen spielen. Das ist so das Minimum, was man braucht, um einen Computer zu haben, auf Basis von so einem Chip. RAM, ROM, irgendeinen Ausgabe-Chip und die CPU. Und dann halt irgendwie PINs, wo man dann was dranhängt. Und wenn man sich so einen C64 anschaut, ist er halt auf dem selben Design im Grunde. Ist halt die selbe CPU, hat auch RAM, hat auch ROM. Und dann sind halt noch ein paar Chips dabei. Wie zum Beispiel erstmal ein Videocontroller. Sowas hatte der Kimmon gar nicht. Das war wirklich nur zum Ausprobieren, zum Spielen. Da war eine kleine Tastatur und so ein kleines Hex-Display dran. So ein sechsstelliges. Also ein C64 hat dann normal einen gescheiten Videocontroller. Das heißt hinten hackt man sich ein Fernseher ran. Oder halt irgendwas, was S-Video kann. Der gute alte PAL oder NTSC-Standard. Und da war noch ein guter Soundcontroller drin. Und im Grunde ist das schon ein Unterschied.
S-Video hatte der nicht. Der hatte doch ein normales Composite-Video.
Nein, S-Video. Es kommt ein Composite-Signal raus, aber auch S-Video. Also kannst Chroma und Luma einzeln abgreifen. Wirklich hinten in diesen DIN-Stecker, ja. Macht ein deutlich besseres Bild.
Ja, aber es gab damals keine Monitore, die das irgendwie konnten. Ich hatte zumindest so einen Bernstein-Monitor, der gab. Das halt nur...
Ja gut, hättest du einen Farbmonitor gehabt. Da hättest du wirklich ein Farbe gehabt. Ein Farbmonitor, Junge. Du hattest einen C64, der 16 wunderbare, brilliante, gestochene Farben hatte.
Ja, auf dem Fernseher. Aber ein Farbmonitor war doch damals jenseits jeglichen, also das gab's nicht. Zumindest nicht zu irgendwie bezahlbaren Preisen.
Also geben tut sie, weil ich hab dann nachher gebraucht, solche auch mal gekauft. Also die originalen.
Ich hab eigentlich aus der Zeit von 1984, 1985.
Ich hab ein Baujahr 84 und ein Farbmonitor. Von Commodore selber, ja klar. Keine Ahnung, was der mal gekostet hat, aber den hab ich halt im Gebrauchtladen gefunden.
Na ja, war für mich auf jeden Fall nicht machbar.
Ja, war halt dann auch wirklich schärfer. Das Problem ist halt von so einem PAL-Signal, dass das, wenn das über eine... Das ist immer das eine, aber wenn du es über Composites so drüber tust, wegen dieser Farbkodierung... Wegen dieser Farbkodierung ist es so, dass manche Farbkombinationen, wenn du irgendwie rot auf blau hast oder sowas, dann beißt sich das im Farbkodiersignal und so. Und deswegen haben viele Farben oft nicht gut ausgesehen, weil die meisten Leute doch ein Fernseher dahinten taten. Da musste man immer ein bisschen aufpassen.
Aber das ist natürlich so eine Eigenschaft dieser frühen Homecomputer gewesen, dass die einfach dann gleich noch so ein fernsehkompatibles Signal erzeugen konnten und dann einfach Antenne und zack.
Ja, alle konnten es nicht. Der Apple II zum Beispiel, da musstest du einen echten Apple II-Monitor haben.
Ah, den hatte ich nicht.
Beim Amiga war es dann aber halt wieder ein Nachteil. Da wurde ja alles genau so gebaut, dass man den Fernseher dran hängen konnte und dann irgendwann hatten die Leute das Problem, alle Monitore, die ich an Amiga hänge, die flimmern ja. Die haben den Chip nie geupdatet, weil das Prinzip war immer noch, dass der eben ein 50-Hz-Signal rausbringt. Aber gut, zu einer gewissen Zeit war das eben ein Vorteil.
Ja, weil Fernseher waren dann weit verbreitet, konnte man dann auch stützeln. Genau, so haben es ja auch die Spielekonsolen gemacht und so machen sie es am Prinzip auch heute noch. Das ist ja nur andere Standards, die mittlerweile zum Einsatz kommen. Okay, das heißt der Prozessor ist quasi das Herz der ganzen Geschichte. Dann gab es halt das Grafik-Subsystem.
Ein schöner Chip namens VIC, ja?
Der Video Interface Chip.
Video Interface Controller.
Damals kannte man auch wirklich noch so jeden Chip persönlich.
Auf dem Amiga hatten die ja noch richtige Mädchen-Namen, Baun-Namen. Im C64 hatten die nur Abkürzungen. VIC, der Video Interface Controller. Genauer gesagt, das ist der VIC-2. Weil im alten VC-20, oder der VC-20, der Vorgänger vom C64, da kommt auch der Name her. Deswegen heißt der auch VC-20. In Deutschland VC-20. Das I hat man rausgenommen, weil es sich sonst doof anhört, wenn man es ausspricht. Und der hatte den VIC eben drin und das war die zweite Version, die deutlich bessere Version. Und das SID, das Sound Interface Device. Das ist der Sound-Controller. Drei Stimmen. Genau, die zwei Chips hängen halt noch dran. Der Video-Chip, der Sound-Chip. Aber ansonsten ist das halt dasselbe. RAM, ROM, IO-Controller.
Der Sound-Controller war für damalige Verhältnisse auch wirklich der Brüller.
Der ist prima und Leute machen heutzutage immer noch Musik damit.
Das hat ja auch so ein ganz eigenes Musik-Genre losgetreten. Weil vorher hatten eigentlich die Homecomputer immer nur so Gepiepe. So Beeper und so. Und klar, sie könnten irgendwas machen, aber dass der Sound-Chip halt wirklich so drei verschiedene Stimmen gleichzeitig hatte und man dann so ADSR-Höhlkurve setzen konnte und...
Ja, und was richtig mal neu war, ist, dass ein Sound-Chip von einem Musiker gemacht wurde. Also jemand, der sich wirklich mit Musiktechnik auskennt. Ansonsten immer so, ja, Sound, ja, da müssen wir irgendwie piepsen, rauschen, was gibt's noch? Mit einem Rauschen kannst du irgendwie einen Schuss machen, wenn du dann mit der Lautstärke noch ein bisschen rumspielst und ein Piepsen ist okay für Musik, vielleicht zwei Piepser, okay. Ich mein, später gab es natürlich ein gutes professionelles Soundzeug, was dann Creative Labs und sowas gemacht hat. Die haben sich schon mit sowas dann ausgekannt. Aber zu der Zeit war das eigentlich neu, dass man von der Sichtweite wirklich, von Sichtweite, von wie mache ich eigentlich Musik gemacht wurde.
Das ist im Prinzip ein richtiger Synthesizer gewesen.
Ja, der auch heutzutage, also kannst du ja heutzutage Keyboards kaufen mit so einem Chip drin. Da kaufen Leute, also wenn du mal auf eBay schaust und suchst nach C64 Mainboard, dann findest du Boards ohne den C-Chip. Denn da ist eine echte Industrie dahinter, dass Leute auf eBay C64 kaufen, die Boards wieder verkaufen, den C-Chip rausnehmen und den C-Chip einzeln verkaufen oder den C-Chip in irgendwelchen Keyboards und Synthesizers verkaufen. Also wirklich, das Emulation würde es eigentlich auch tun, aber so viele Leute bestehen darauf.
Die bauen sich dann noch so eine kleine Elektronik drumherum und dann was noch so, dass man die Hüllkurve dann direkt am Keyboard einstellen kann oder was so irgendwie.
Damit kenne ich mich jetzt auch nicht so aus. Ich denke schon, ja. Krass. Dass das so läuft oder dass man es an MIDI anschließt und dann halt fernsteuert.
Und das muss der richtige Original-Chip sein, so wie das vergoldete Kabel und so.
Ja, weil der Chip hat eben auch analoge Eigenschaften. Man könnte sich ja denken, es ist alles Digital-Technik. Da kann man einfach einen Emulator schreiben. Man weiß ja, wie der funktioniert. Man muss den einfach nur mal verstehen und nachprogrammieren. Aber beim SIT-Chip, da hängen auch so ein paar Filter und so was drin, die wirklich in dem Chip eingegossen sind, in analog. So ein halb analog, halb digitaler Chip. Und das eben dann nicht mehr hundertprozentig, in der Theorie nicht hundertprozentig abzubilden.
Verstehe.
Immer nur anzunähern.
Und da kommen dann so die Päpste der Audio-Technologien, nein, nur der Original SIT-Chip kann leisten, was ein Original SIT-Chip leisten kann.
Der große Punkt beim SIT-Chip ist aber auch, es gibt zwei Hauptrevisionen von dem Chip. Das ist der alte 6581 und der neuere 8580. Und die Geschichte dahinter ist eigentlich, dass sie den SIT nicht rechtzeitig fertig gekriegt haben damals. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, okay, die Features funktionieren nicht richtig, da sind noch Bugs drin. Aber gut, dann darf man sie halt eben nicht verwenden und haben den SIT halt so raus geblasen. Und also 82 wurde jetzt C64 eingeführt. Ich glaube, das war 86, als sie dann diese oder 87, wo sie die Hauptrevision gemacht haben, vom Board und da war dann der neue SIT-Chip drauf und der hatte die ganzen Fehlerbereinigungen drin. Und die Leute haben sich alle aufgeregt und gesagt, ja, das hört sich ja nicht mehr so an wie der alte. Und die ganze alte Musik hat sich ein bisschen anders angehört. Zum Beispiel kennst du Janna Sisters? Und da gibt es ja so ein Rauschen am Anfang. Also im Spiel die Musik ist ein sehr angenehmes Rauschen. Das hat sich beim neuen total anders angehört. Und dann haben halt teilweise die Leute es gefixt und die Programme wieder ein bisschen umgeschrieben. Manche Leute haben halt ein Lied komponiert für den alten und für den neuen dann nochmal extra. Oder halt gesagt, du musst das unbedingt auf einem alten oder auf einem neuen anhören. Also die alten sind auch die Wichtigeren, die man eher will. Eigentlich eher geschichtlich, weil die frühen Musik ist einfach für den alten gemacht worden und viele Leute hängen deswegen noch am alten.
Der 6581, ein Wundersteinchen. Ja, also die Videofähigkeiten des C64 waren ja für damalige Verhältnisse gut. Würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, außergewöhnlich.
Doch, das würde ich sagen. Ja, wenn man es so vergleicht, was gab es denn gleichzeitig? Den Apple II, da gab es einige Revisionen vom Apple II schon, aber da konnte fast gar nichts. Vor allem, der hatte keinen Videochip, sondern der hat einfach nur diese 74 LS-Bausteine zusammengebastelt, um so was wie einen Framebuffer oder einen Character-Decoder zu haben. Der hat keine Modi, also vielleicht nach Grafik und Text. Es war alles sehr, sehr trivial so mit, ich lese Pixel und ich stelle die dar. Was das Problem ist an sich bei diesem Ansatz, ist, wenn man einfach nur Pixel liest, wenn ich jetzt sagen will, ich will 16 Farben und ich will in 320 x 200 Bild. Was jetzt C64 darstellen kann, das ist die Auflösung, das sind die Farben. Wenn man dann schaut, wie viel Speicher brauche ich, um das abzulegen, dann komme ich auf 32 Kilobyte. Und 32 Kilobyte ist schon die Hälfte vom Hauptspeicher. Und die meisten Maschinen von damals hatten ja noch nicht mal so viel. Das war ja eine Ausnahme, dass der 64K hatte. So ein Apple II damals hatte vielleicht noch 16 oder, ich weiß nicht, was ein Spektrum, 48 oder so was. Und man konnte ja nicht seinen ganzen Speicher auffüllen mit so was. Und deswegen muss eben so ein Videochip sehr schlau sein, dass er eine gute Codierung hat. Dass du sagst, ja ich kann pro 8x8 Feld nur zwei Farben verwenden, vier Farben verwenden, eine davon ist global fürs ganze Bild. Lauter solche Sachen. Insofern hatte der einfach so viele Tricks drin, dass man doch annehmbar gute Bilder hingekriegt hat und dabei vielleicht nur ungefähr 8K an Speicher verbraucht, oder vielleicht mal 16. Also 16 ist das, was der Videochip insgesamt überhaupt adressieren kann. Normalerweise, naja gut, normalerweise Tricks. Es gibt immer 1000 Tricks, was man dann noch alles machen kann. Und auch sonst, wenn man sich den Spektrum anschaut zum Beispiel, der konnte, glaube ich, grundsätzlich immer nur pro 8x8 Pixel zwei Farben haben, weil auch der Videocontroller recht einfach war. Erst dann wieder, gut, Amiga war natürlich dann wieder eine ganz andere Klasse, der auch eigentlich nur drei, vier Jahre später gekommen ist. Aber was dann auch relativ gut war, war dann das Nintendo Entertainment System, also der normale alte Nintendo. Der hatte auch einen recht guten Videochip, der ungefähr in der Klasse von C64 war ein bisschen besser, aber der war eben auch drei Jahre später, 1985. Zu der Zeit waren es eigentlich immer nur relativ einfache Character-Display-Dinger und einfache Bitmap-Controller. Nicht so ganz komplexe Sachen mit Sprites, vor allem auch Sprites.
Also die Möglichkeit, so unabhängig von der eigentlichen High-Res-Grafik, noch andere Pixel-Elemente drüber zu blenden.
Genau, also im Spiel quasi, wenn da so ein Mario drüber läuft, dann ist es eben ein Sprite oder mehrere Sprites aufeinander gelegt, wenn man irgendwie mehr Farben haben will, so als Trick. Und am C64 konnte man eben acht solches Sprites auf dem Bildschirm frei hin und her bewegen, während einfach im Hintergrund irgendwie was dargestellt wurde. Es wurde eben zur Laufzeit, während der Videochip das Bild dargestellt hat, zusammen gecomposited. Und wenn man sich die Chip-Fläche anschaut von so einem VEC, wenn man sich den mal aufbohrt, dann sieht man, dass 80 Prozent davon nur für diese Sprite-Steuerung da war.
Ach echt?
Das heißt, Sprites waren teuer.
Aber Sprites waren natürlich auch der Enabler für Spiele.
Ja, es gibt ja diesen halben Nachfolger vom C64, den Plus-4 oder den C16, der war eigentlich für Business gedacht. Und der wurde so ein bisschen Richtung Business-Segment da so vom Marketing geschoben. Und da hat man einfach alles weggenommen, was man jetzt für so einen Full-Featured-Computer bräuchte, aber für einen Business-Computer nicht. Dann haben wir die Sprites rausgenommen. Und ja, dann kann man schon mal fast keine Spiele mehr machen, weil da muss man echt in Software, muss man da so eine Spielfigur drüberlegen, muss die immer drüber kopieren und dann wieder wegkopieren und wieder an eine neue Position drüber kopieren. Und das ist bei einem Megahertz.
Was natürlich langsam ist. Und natürlich auch noch so ein Feature mit den Sprites war, dass man, glaube ich, auch die Kollision zwischen den Sprites automatisch bekommen hat.
Genau, das ging gleich automatisch. Wenn der beim Zusammenfügen von dem Bild einfach gesehen hat, an dieses Pixel könnte ich jetzt das eine Sprite malen und das andere Sprite gleichzeitig, dann ist es für den Chip gleich automatisch, dass er sieht, okay, da liegt ja eine Kollision vor.
Und das wurde dann über die Hardware zurück an die Software gemeldet und die konnte da entsprechend darauf reagieren.
Genau, ich kann da in einem Register auslesen, welche Sprites haben eigentlich gerade miteinander kollidiert. Und dann sehe ich, mein Spieler-Sprite hat kollidiert mit einem Gegner-Sprite.
Und das war's. Game over.
Ja, wenn man sich da irgendwie einen Trainer schreiben wollte damals oder sowas, musste man halt einfach ein bisschen dissemblieren, schauen, wo dieses Register gelesen wird und einfach sagen, ja, ich lese eine Null.
Ja, jetzt, wo du das so sagst, fällt mir das eigentlich auch wieder ein, dass das eigentlich so im Vergleich zu den anderen Maschinenchen dann doch echt total outstanding war. Also auch, was gab's denn noch? Dann gab's noch so diesen Texas Instruments TI-994A.
Ihr habt ihn noch nie gesehen.
Allein schon der Name ja. Eine furchtbare Gurke. Man hat das Gefühl, der Bildschirm bestand nur aus vier Pixeln. Also das war...
Aber Bill Cosby hat dafür Werbung gemacht.
Naja, gut, den kannte ja hier keiner. Der C64 war damals schon wirklich konkurrenzlos in seinem Appeal auf die C-Gruppe, der ich angehörte damals.
Also überall eigentlich best of class in den ganzen Sachen. Also halt im Homecomputer-Segment.
Na gut, aber lassen wir uns noch mal so ein bisschen bei einem Overview bleiben, um überhaupt erstmal zu verstehen, was eigentlich drin ist in dieser Maschine. Also wir haben festgehalten, das Ding hat einen Prozessor, den 6502.
Fast. Also da könnte man jetzt an der Stelle ein bisschen konkreter werden. Wollt man sagen, es ist ein 6510. Ja. Der ist ein ganz normaler 6502-Core da drin, aber ein Ausgabe-Port ist schon eingebaut, den man fürs Bank-Switching braucht. Also weil eben das Problem ist, so ein 6502 an sich kann nur mit 64 Kilobyte an Speicher umgehen. Immer wenn ich eine Adresse hab, dann muss die halt 16-Bit groß sein, anders geht das nicht. Und der hat ja schon 64 Kilobyte an Hauptspeicher eingebaut. Und ja, wie könnte ich denn jetzt noch auf so einen Sit-Chip zugreifen, weil der muss auch irgendwie über den Speicher zugreifbar sein. Oder das ROM. Und deswegen muss man zwischen den umschalten können. Dann sag ich einfach, ich will an der Adresse jetzt das ROM sehen. Oder nee, ich will sie jetzt gerade mal nicht sehen, weil ich das RAM sehen will an der Stelle. Und da gibt es so ein paar Speicher-Bereiche, wo man es ein- und ausschalten kann. Deswegen gibt es in die CPU eingebaut so einen kleinen Port, der immer da ist, so dass ich dann hin- und herschalten kann zwischen den unterschiedlichen Memory-Layouts. Und das ist das, was den 6510 ausmacht. Ansonsten ist es ein ganz normaler 6510.
Aber so hat es die Maschine geschafft, in einem 64K-Adressraum sowohl 64K RAM unterzubringen, als auch andere Dinge, die adressiert werden können, wie zum Beispiel das ROM. Wie viel war das nochmal? 8 KB? 16 KB? 16 KB?
Also das war mal das Betriebssystem. Das heißt Kernel. Das ist so eine Bibliothek, die für eine Ausgabe zuständig ist und diesen Screen-Editor hat, das im Hemdkursor rumsausen kann auf dem Bildschirm und wo ich was drucken kann. Wo ich auf eine Floppy zugreifen kann und so weiter. Das waren 7 KB und dann nochmal 9 KB dieses BASIC, das eingebaut war. Das war von Microsoft lizenziert, das Microsoft BASIC und ja genau.
Das war von Microsoft?
Ja klar. Wusstest du nicht.
Nein.
Das Microsoft BASIC.
Bist du sicher?
Da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Das Commodore BASIC war von Microsoft?
Ja.
Krass.
Die Geschichte von dem Microsoft BASIC, um da mal einen kleinen Exkurs zu machen, die haben das, die haben 75, haben sie für den 8080, für diese Intel-CPU, haben sie dieses BASIC geschrieben und dann, als der 6502 rauskam, haben sie es darüber portiert, es war dann ungefähr 9 Kilobyte in der Größe her, für den Kim-1 gab es das dann auch schon, Commodore hat das in die Pads eingebaut und in alle anderen 8-Bit-Computer und selbst Apple hat das lizenziert, die späteren Apple IIs, die hatten das eingebaut. Das war auch total lustig, weil damals gab es so eine große Partitionierung zwischen den unterschiedlichen Hacker-Leuten, die Leute, die zum Beispiel einen Apple hatten und die Leute, die einen Commodore hatten, die hatten nichts miteinander zu prünen eigentlich, obwohl sie fast genau dieselbe Maschine hatten, die hatten dieselbe BASIC eingebaut und dann haben die Apple-Leute irgendwie einen Bug im BASIC gefunden und die Commodore-Leute haben einen Bug im BASIC gefunden, da gab es hier eine Zeitschrift, da eine Zeitschrift, es ist ganz selten, dass da mal irgendwie der eine auch mal die andere Maschine gesehen hätte oder gesehen hätte, hey, das ist ja genau dasselbe. Heutzutage kann man das ja sehr schön analysieren, das habe ich auch mal analysiert, ich habe ich glaube ich zehn verschiedene Versionen von BASIC für die unterschiedlichsten Computersysteme genommen, die alle auf Microsoft BASIC basiert haben und einfach mal gesehen, geschaut, was sind die Unterschiede, wann hat wer einen Source-Drop von Microsoft gekriegt und wieder mal Fehlerbereinigungen und so weiter und das man halt auch ganz klar sieht, du kannst aus einem Quelltext halt ein BASIC für Commodore basteln, also kompilieren oder eins für Apple oder für diverse andere kleine Maschinen.
Hihi, okay. Also 16 Kilobyte.
Und dann halt noch ein Character-ROM, wo der Zeichensatz drin steht. Der ist, glaube ich, vier. Das muss man mal rechnen. 256 Zeichen, zwei Zeichensätze und acht Byte pro Zeichen. Das sind, glaube ich, 4K. Kannst du mal rechnen?
Ja, hier steht das. Es gab acht. Acht und vier Kilobyte ROM. Das würde ja deine These bestätigen. Tja, unglaubliche Speichermengen. 64 Kilobyte. Ich meine, heutzutage...
65.536 Bytes. Wie kann man noch zählen?
Heute hat man schon Icons, die mehr Speicherplatz brauchen. Das ist echt absurd. Und da passten halt Textverarbeitungsprogramme rein, Datenbanken, Spiele aller Art. Es war...
Ja, auch das Geos-Betriebssystem.
Unglaublich.
Hattest du Geos?
Nee, das ist dann wirklich schon nach meiner Zeit gewesen.
86 kam so aus, oder? Doch, 86 kam es 111, 112.
Jaja, also ich hab das noch so mitbekommen, dass das so kam mit einer Maus und so weiter.
Eine richtige UI-Bedienung. Die haben wirklich den Apple Macintosh damals wirklich eins zu eins geklont. Das schaut ganz genauso aus. Also ich hab ja auch mit Geos ein bisschen rumgespielt, hab dann später mal gesehen... Ich interessiere mich ja für Computergeschichte allgemein, hab dann Apple Macintosh gesehen. Hab gesehen, die haben... Aha, das kenne ich ja alles, weil Geos wirklich eine perfekte Kopie war. Auch eigentlich vom Design, wie sie das intern gelöst haben. Also das war damals... Also das ist schon beeindruckend, dass man wirklich eine grafische Bedienoberfläche mit Mausbedienung in so eine winzige Kiste reinkriegt.
Ich meine, hat denn das irgendwas gebracht?
Textverarbeitung mit Visivic, ja sicher. Also da gab es sogar ein DTP-Programm dafür. Du konntest wirklich... Da haben Leute ihre Vereinszeitungen richtig schön mit Visivic gebastelt. Da konntest du hier mal eine Headline hinbauen mit der Schriftart, du konntest die Schriftarten von anderen Leuten kaufen. Große Sache. Es war halt schon ein bisschen langsam. Es war unglaublich langsam. Aber man hat die Features gekriegt, die gab es ja sonst fast gar nicht.
Na gut, es gab den Atari ST, der ja gerade so...
Guter mit Atari oder Amiga, guter bist du aber dann schon sehr teuer gewesen damals.
Ja, das war halt beim C64 aber auch noch. Mich hat das damals nicht so interessiert bzw. da bin ich dann schon in andere Maschinenrichtungen marschiert. Da hatte ich dann nicht mehr so das Interesse. Aber ich bin ja auch eher so wie du so ein unten, also ich fühlte mich eigentlich immer so ein bisschen auf der Systemebene am wohlsten.
Ein ganz kranker Vergleich noch, wenn man vergleicht, wie schnell die CPU läuft. Die Geschwindigkeit, mit der vom Hauptspeicherdaten gelesen werden können auf einem C64, ist langsamer als eine heutige DSL-Leitung.
Ach echt?
Also wenn man den Speicher irgendwo anders auf der Welt hinstellen würde und den für die Internet und dann mit einer normalen DSL-Leitung auf der anderen Seite tunneln würde, ja gut, die Latency ist dann natürlich schlecht, aber das ist ungefähr der Durchsatz, den man kriegt.
Das heißt, der Prozessor wäre nicht in der Lage, eine DSL-Leitung zu saturieren, selbst im besten?
Ja, also theoretisch der Speicher. Der Speicher läuft mit 2 MHz darauf, praktisch, weil nämlich der Videocontroller und die CPU teilen sich den Speicher. Weil der Videocontroller muss er die ganze Zeit den Speicher immer wieder auslesen, damit er ihn zum Fernseher schicken kann, als analoges Signal. Und deswegen immer in jedem zweiten Takt, also wenn man jetzt von 2 MHz ausgeht, liest immer der Videochip und in den restlichen Takten liest die CPU, somit läuft die CPU mit einem MHz und der Videochip liest halt auch mit einem MHz von dem RAM aus. Das heißt 1 MB pro Sekunde, 8 MB.
Unglaublich.
Aber die CPU dann effektiv natürlich, wenn du noch ein Programm schreiben musst, das wirklich Speicher kopiert, bist du wieder langsamer, weil du nicht in jedem Zyklus lesen kannst.
Ja, aber das stimmt. Ich kann mich auch noch erinnern, dass wenn man so in diesen High-Resolution-Modus geschaltet hat und dann wirklich knallhart einfach ein Programm schreibt, was einfach nur in diesen Speicher irgendwas reingeschrieben hat, also was weiß ich, ich machs alle Bits auf 1, ich machs irgendwie alles auf hell, in so einem monochromen Modus, da konnte man wirklich noch die Linie von links nach rechts und von oben nach unten laufen sehen.
Ja, wenn du so BASIC geschrieben hast, oder?
Na, in was war denn das? Also in BASIC war es so richtig, richtig lahm.
Das hat so 20 Sekunden gedauert, den Bildschirm zu löschen, wenn du einen High-Res Bildschirm hattest.
Aber auch wenn man es in December geschrieben hat, es war nicht so instantan, dass man das irgendwie...
Es waren ein paar Frames. Also du konntest es noch sehen.
Genau, man konnte es noch sehen. Also man sah noch so richtig, wie der Speicherbereich gefüllt wurde. Es war jetzt nicht so wie Modemgeschwindigkeit, dass es langsam beim Bildschirm kroch, aber es war eine Bewegung zu erkennen.
Und da sieht man mal wieder, also dieser Videochip, der da eingebaut ist, der hat eben einen Haufen Tricks drin, dass man solche Sachen gar nicht machen musste. Zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Spiel gehabt hast, irgendwie so ein Jump'n'Run oder so was, wo was nach rechts oder nach links scrollt, ist das ja dann auf späteren Rechnern so gewesen oder auf dem PC immer so, so Commander Keen aus den Zeiten, war es so, da wurde einfach der Bildschirm die ganze Zeit umkopiert. Ich musste den Bildschirm einfach um einen Pixel nach links kopieren, aber das wäre einfach zu langsam gewesen. Deswegen konnte der Videochip halt, da hatte er einfach so einen tiefen Support, dass ich sage, stell doch den Bildschirm einfach mal um einen Pixel weiter nach links dar. Acht horizontal, acht vertikal. Und wenn ich dann halt acht weiter gescrollt habe, dann muss ich einmal umkopieren. Aber trotzdem hat man es nicht geschafft, dass man, oder schwer geschafft, einen High-Res-Bildschirm komplett umzukopieren, immer ausreichend. Sondern dafür gab es eben dann den Trick von diesem Tiled-Modus, das funktioniert so ähnlich wie ein Text-Modus, dass ich für jeden Charakter auf dem Bildschirm einfach so einen Teil hinterlege und mir da durch meinen Bildschirm zusammen bastle. Also ich meine, jedes so ein Jump-and-Run-Spiel, da sieht man ja, dass sich alles auch wiederholt. Das ist im Endeffekt ja nichts anderes wie ein Zeichensatz, nur ein geänderter Zeichensatz. Und dann muss ich nicht so viel umkopieren. Ich muss eben nur 1000 bytes umkopieren, was halt die 40 mal 25 Charakters sind. Und das geht ja 0,0 im Vergleich, statt den 8 Kilobyte.
Das heißt, man hat die ganze Zeit mit Zeichensatzredefinition gearbeitet.
Ja, bzw. wenn ich den Zeichensatz einfach nur mal ändere, dann habe ich einen High-Res-Modus, dann habe ich die volle Auflösung, da 20, 200 und kann in jedem Zeichen eben nur eine Vordergrundfarbe und Hintergrundfarbe haben, was doch sehr eingeschränkt ist. Und für Spiele gibt es dann den Multicolor-Modus, dann fülle ich die halbe horizontale Auflösung. Aber ich habe dann die Möglichkeit für, glaube ich, vier Farben pro Character. Und das ist so das, was die meisten Spiele, die meisten scrollenden Spiele, die ganzen Jump'n'Runs und so ein R-Type oder ein Catechis.
Das heißt, die Auflösung ging runter, man hatte zumindest noch ein paar Farben, aber dafür könnte es einfach sehr schnell sein. Und es kam viel Bewegung rein und das war natürlich für die Damen und Herren genau das Entscheidende.
Man konnte in verschiedene Kompromiss-Modi schalten. Entweder volle Auflösung, Mittel, noch ein bisschen weniger, ganz wenig. Und das ist dann eine Geschwindigkeitsfrage oder halt eine Farbenfrage. Da waren ein paar gute Kombinationen eingebaut. Und sowas hatten eben andere Maschinen gar nicht. Die hatten immer nur den kleinen Modus und den großen Modus.
Da sind wir schon wieder so ein bisschen abgekommen von dem System-Overview. Ich frage mich auch gerade, ob es vielleicht einfach besser ist, hier durch die einzelnen Komponenten durchzumaschieren und die dann für sich zu besprechen. Was hatten wir denn jetzt? Also wir hatten den Prozessor, du hast mich korrigiert, das ist ein 6510, das ist ein 6502 plus diesem kleinen Feature, dass man eben auch einen Computer haben kann, der über den vollkommenen Adressraum Speicher hat und dann aber auch noch andere Dinge. Und dann muss man immer so hin und her schalten. Das war das Besondere an dem C64. Also das kann man sich ja heutzutage überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen, aber es klappten allen die Minder herunter, als das Announcement kam, dass halt 64 Kilobyte RAM in diesem Computer sein würde. Ja, das war einfach shocking news, weil alles andere hatte so, naja, also 1420 hatte 16, das war schon relativ viel so und 64K, das ging irgendwie gar nicht. Und dann kam ja gleich dieser Klassiker, wurde eigentlich mit dem C64 geboren, so das kriegt man ja nie voll. Was soll man denn in 64 Kilobyte, was soll man denn da überhaupt alles reinkriegen?
Na ja, aber das sind schon auch so Zahlen, wo man sich vorstellen kann, ich meine, wenn man halt Text schreibt, dann ist, wenn man 4 Kilobyte, ist eine DIN A4-Seite, mit 80 mal 60 sowas. Und dann wie viele Seiten sind das dann? 4K, 64, sind dann 16, 16 Seiten, oder? 16 DIN A4-Seiten. Recht viel mehr ist es nicht. Also so eine Dissertation passt nicht rein.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dann muss man halt dann die Kapitel 1 machen.
Oder auf Tape speichern. Ich hatte am Anfang eine Datasette, weil das war halt noch so halbwegs erschwinglich und das Diskettenlaufwerk, das war ja eher so in unerreichbarer Weite.
Ja, sogar ich hatte noch eins, also ein halbes Jahr lang hatte ich auch ein Datasettenlaufwerk, weil ich halt auf meinen Geburtstag warten musste, bis ich mir dann das Floppy-Laufwerk wünschen konnte.
Das war wirklich auch die Definition von langsam, also da konnte man nur wirklich jedes Bit noch einzeln begutachten, während es auf das Band geschrieben wurde.
Ja, ich glaube so 300 Boot.
Also eigentlich so wie die Datenkommunikation angefangen hat, so Fernübertragung, also 300 Bit pro Sekunde, um genau zu sein. Und das Tape war einfach genauso lahm.
Ja, im Grunde war es nichts anderes als ein Modem mit einem Tape dahinter.
Genau.
Man gibt es nicht an jemand anderes, sondern man speichert es mal fest.
Man hat es einfach auf Magnetband geschrieben.
Und was noch ein bisschen kritischer ist an der Stelle, wenn das Magnetband beim Abspielen halt nicht genau dieselbe Drehzahl hat, dann hast du ein Problem. Und wenn du was live funkst, dann hast du das Problem ja nicht. Die Zeitkomponente ist da schon konstant. Deswegen war es noch ein bisschen kritischer.
Wenn das Band eiert, oh man, oh man, oh man. Na gut, aber lass uns noch mal so ein bisschen die Systemarchitektur verdeutlichen. Also wir haben diesen Prozessor und er hat so zwei große Freunde, den Videospieherchip, der war ja auch für das RAM-Refresh zuständig gewesen, oder? Diese RAMs mussten regelmäßig, was passiert denn da eigentlich?
Ja, das, wenn ich wüsste. Also ich weiß, das ist auch nur so ein bisschen oberflächlich. Das ist so eine Sache, die man ja von Softwareseite gar nicht mitkriegt. Aber anscheinend ist es so, dass man bei den DRAMs, das warst wahrscheinlich jetzt du besser, oder? Das war jetzt nur eine Fangfrage.
Nee, ich weiß genau das, aber ich habe auch nie so richtig verstanden, warum eigentlich.
Ich glaube, man muss wirklich jede Speicherzelle hin und wieder mal lesen. Wenn man das nicht tut, dann verliert das irgendwann einen Wert. Und damit refresht man das. Und der VEC, wenn halt irgendwie nichts los ist, wenn er nichts zu tun hat, dann geht er halt den Speicher so sequenziell oder nach irgendeiner Strategie durch und liest das einmal so und macht nichts damit. Und dann behält das auch das Ganze. Da gab es dann auch mal irgendwann einen Bug, aber das würde zu weit führen.
Na gut, also auf jeden Fall, der WIC war so ein integraler Bestandteil. Das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so eine Grafikkarte oder so, sondern das ist einfach wirklich so Teil des Systems. Der Soundchip wiederum war eigentlich nur eine Soundkarte, kann man so sagen. Der hat ja sonst keine housekeeping Funktion übernommen, oder?
Ja, also wenn du den WIC rausnimmst, dann startet er gar nichts, dann ist das Ding tot. Wenn du einen Soundchip rausnimmst, dann geht er, aber das ist kein Sound.
Genau.
Dann die zwei IO. Controller, gehen wir mal weiter.
Genau, also wir hatten noch RAM, das ist jetzt häufig genug gesagt worden, 64 KB, dann haben wir eben diese drei ROM-Steine, wo quasi das Betriebssystem und das BASIC später haben sie die vereint, hatten sie nur noch zwei, also es ist höher integriert halt dann. Und dann IO.?
Dann haben wir noch diese zwei IO. Bausteine.
6526, oder?
Das ist nicht die hier? CIA hießen die. Das sind die Nachfolge, also Complex Interface Adapter.
Die CIA.
Die zwei CIA. Das sind Nachfolge von, also der VC20 hatte damals noch die Versatile Interface Adapters, die VIAs. Das ist ein ganz altes Design, das damals MOS noch gemacht hat und das Commodore mit aufgekauft hat. Und das ist jetzt ein verbessertes Design. Im Endeffekt tun die nichts anderes als ein paar Pins, als ein paar I.O.Pins zur Verfügung stellen. Also, dass man so etwas wie, dass man halt Kommunikation machen kann mit einem Joystick, mit einer Tastatur, mit einem Diskettenlaufwerk oder mit was man sonst noch irgendwie ran löten will. Und auf der anderen Seite haben die Timer eingebaut. Das heißt, die messen Zeit, die können Zeit zählen und die können mir Interrupts geben, sodass der CPU immer mal wieder gesagt wird, jetzt solltest du vielleicht mal dieses oder jenes tun. Das sind die zwei Features oder die zwei Aufgaben, die die haben. Und es sind zwei Steine eben da, weil man einfach so viele IO. Leitungen braucht. Man hat mir gedacht, gut, wir haben den Stein jetzt schon designt, machen wir halt einfach zwei davon. Der eine, der hängt an Tastatur und Joystick und der andere, den hängen wir an den Floppy-Port. Und dann sind auch ein paar Leitungen übrig, da hängen wir den User-Port dran. Dann kann jeder sich selber was basteln und da hinten auch irgendwie seine Eisenbahn steuern.
Das war auch so eines der cooleren Features vom C64, dass es einfach so ein Port gab, der einfach nur IO hatte und der vom Betriebssystem keinerlei besondere Funktionen zugewiesen wurde. Und das wurde ja dann auch fleißig getan. Also ich hab das selber, weiß ich gar nicht, hab ich da auch mal was mitgemacht im User-Port? Nee, ich war nicht so der Hardware-Basteltyp. Aber ich kenne eine Menge Leute, die da mit so allerlei Steuerungen gemacht haben.
Ja, das ist interessant, wenn man sich heutzutage, also ich hab ja vor kurzem erst bei eBay noch ein paar C64 ersteigert und irgendwie die Hälfte davon, also die Garantiesiegel waren mal alle kaputt. Alle haben das Ding aufgeschraubt und mal reingeschaut. Und die Hälfte davon hat noch irgendwas auf dem Mainboard rumgelötet. Da haben Leute sich teilweise wirklich was reingelötet. Ich meine, es war der User-Port da, da konnte man gleich mal nach außen was steuern. Und das Allereinfachste ist, man lötet sich eine LED an jedes Pin ran und dann hat man so eine kleine Lichterkette und kann so einen Nitride-Effekt sich programmieren. Mehr braucht man gar nicht und von BASIC aus schreibt man dann so ein kleines Programm, das ein bisschen Poke macht und schon blinken die Lichter. Aber die Leute sind dann teilweise auch noch sehr viel weitergegangen und haben wirklich an ihren C64 drinnen rumgelötet. Weil eben alles so, man kommt halt noch an alles. Die ganzen Traces, die ganzen Lötpunkte sind halt da, dass man sich da einfach mal was hinhängen kann. Also auch Hardware-Bastler, ja. Das ist interessant, ich glaube, die erste Generation an C64-Leuten, das waren zum einen mal schon die Programmierer, die Informatiker oder so, die Software-Bastler auf der anderen Seite, aber so mehr die E-Techniker. Da waren Haufen E-Techniker, die das halt interessant fanden. Die sind mehr so von der oder die Funka. Das waren so damals die Kulturen, die damals auf das Ding eingehakt haben.
Der klassische Hardware-Hack, das hatte wirklich fast jeder. Man hat sich so ein Resett-Taster eingebaut.
Ja, ich frage mich, warum sie den nicht standardmäßig eingebaut hatten. Vor allem auch die ganzen Revisionen, zwölf Jahre hergestellt, und sie haben nie die Resett-Taster eingebaut.
Ja, weil man konnte ja das Ding schnell zack zack aushalten und war ja auch instantan oben.
Das Problem ist, was ist, wenn du den Speicher nicht verlieren wolltest? Ich meine, spätestens seit Jake Applebaum und Codeboot-Attacks weiß man ja, wenn man Speicher ausschaltet, schnell wieder einschaltet, ist das meiste noch da. Aber was ist, wenn ich ein Programm geschrieben habe, habe ich nicht abgespeichert, habe es laufen lassen, ist abgestürzt, so böse abgestürzt, dass ich nicht mehr rauskomme?
Ja, dafür hat man es natürlich dann verwendet, aber die meisten hatten natürlich dafür nicht unbedingt so den Bedarf. So eine Kiste lief halt nicht, dann schalt man wieder neu ein und dann...
Ja, das ist die Frage. Also im Grunde haben doch die meisten ihn nur als Spielekonsole verwendet. Also gerade später dann. Aber jetzt mal so im Vergleich. Wie viel Prozent wohl programmiert haben auf dem Ding und wirklich Sachen gemacht haben, die wirklich nicht nur Konsumieren von Informationen ist, sondern richtig, ich will mich mit dem Ding auseinandersetzen und was lernen. Es wurde ja auch teilweise als Lerncomputer positioniert. So was wie, kannst du eine Spielekonsole kaufen? Oder, also beim VC20 wurde das auch in der Werbung so gemacht. Oder, kauf halt einen VC20, das ist ein richtiger Computer, da lernt man auch was. Und da gab es auch so eine schöne Werbung bei einem Vorstellungsgespräch. So, und was können sie denn zum Thema Computer sagen? Und dann erzählt er halt von Space Invaders und so. Und dann sitzt ein anderer da und, ja, ich hatte einen VC20, ich kann BASIC programmieren. Das war so damals das, was man so an Computerkenntnissen haben musste, dass man ein bisschen programmieren konnte. Und heutzutage gibt es das ja gar nicht mehr. Wenn du mal so in die Breite schaust von Leuten, die Computer haben, wie viel davon?
Also ich habe da keine gute Antwort darauf. Ich würde fast sagen, das Verhältnis ist eigentlich immer noch dasselbe. Es gibt heutzutage viel mehr Leute, die auch programmieren können, aber im Verhältnis zu denen, die einen haben, ist es immer noch dieselbe Quote. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sich da so sehr viel geändert hat. Es ist natürlich schwer zu sagen, für mich ist es zumindest schwer zu sagen, weil ich natürlich auch gleich wieder in so eine Szene von technikbegeisterten Jugendlichen geraten bin, wo natürlich der Anteil relativ hoch war. Trotzdem gab es viele, die hatten eigentlich nur am Spieletauschen Interesse. Die sind deshalb in diese nachmittaglichen Kaufhaus-Sessions hineingeraten, einfach um ihre Softwareversorgung sicherzustellen. Weil es gab natürlich kein Internet, wo man sich was runterladen konnte. Und die Quelle, die Kopierquelle, war halt einfach in den Läden, wo die Kids vor diesen öffentlichen Maschinen rumgammelten. Und da machte man dann halt eben auch so seine Kontakte. Und da tauscht man eben auch sein Wissen über diese ganzen Maschinen aus.
Ach ja, ich komme ja eher vom Land. Da gab es ja keine Läden.
Ja, ich bin ja so ein Stadtei.
Ja, bei mir Muriloch hat auf dem Schulhof getauscht.
Ja, genau, Schulen. Wobei, ja, das war dann bei mir wiederum nicht so gängig. Ja, naja, also, aber es gab definitiv Leute, die natürlich auch unbedingt diese Begierde hatten zu verstehen. Und das war eigentlich auch bei mir so ein bisschen das Treibende. Also ich konnte mich nicht so richtig zufriedengeben mit so einem Gerät, was so vor mir steht und sagt, du, ich funktioniere halt einfach irgendwie und ich muss das nicht weiter interessieren. Das hat mir einfach keine Ruhe gelassen. Das waren schlaflose Nächte. Das kann doch nicht schon die ganze Antwort gewesen sein. Das muss doch irgendwie auch besser verstehbar sein. Und dann sind wir auch wieder so beim Einstieg zu der Sendung, wo du sagtest, es ist einfach hackable und dort kann man so seinen Wunsch nach Verstehen der Komplexität des Gesamtsystems ganz gut bedienen. Das stimmt. Und wenn man dann das erste Mal auf die Maschinenebene, also ich war auch mit diesem BASIC nicht zufrieden, wenn man das erste Mal dann halt den Assembler küsst, dann setzen so die Aha-Effekte ein. Und ich denke, das ist natürlich etwas, was heutzutage vielen einfach fehlt. Hochsprachen, alles klar, wunderbar, so, aber man weiß, auch die wird dann auch mal irgendwie unten in Maschinencode übersetzt und was tut denn das? Und das ist natürlich für die meisten Leute auch der totale Voodoo. Wann bist du denn da so eingestiegen auf die Ebene und wie hast du das so empfunden?
Ja, so 1989 habe ich ihn ja gekriegt, Ende 89.
Da warst du dann wie alt?
Zehn. Ja, da wollte ich eigentlich eine Spielkonsole, irgendwie so ein Freund von mir hatte so ein Atari und dann so, ja ich will ein Atari, aber dann gab es eben gerade den im Sonnenangebot und wo ich ihn hatte, habe ich dann erst festgestellt, Moment mal, so viele Leute, die ich kenne, hatten ja genau den. Also ich habe da überhaupt keine Ahnung von dem ganzen Zeugs gehabt, habe dann auch anfangs halt so ein bisschen mit Spielen hin und her getan. Aber das Schöne war ja, da war das Benutzerhandbuch dabei, also obwohl das das Supergame-Paket war, haben sie das normale Benutzerhandbuch dazu gepackt und darin ist halt ein Basic-Kurs, der jetzt nicht besonders toll ist, aber wenn man einfach die Programme einmal der Reihe nach abtippt, dann versteht man irgendwann, was das alles bedeutet. Und dann hat man sich so ein 64er Magazin gekauft, oder Magic Disk war damals auch groß, das war glaube ich nach deiner Zeit, oder? Das kam ja erst ab 87 bis 96, gab es einen Disketten-Magazin, im Endeffekt der Nachfolger von der Input 64.
Ja, das kenne ich noch.
Das war ja auch Anfang auf Tape rausgekommen, aber auch dann gleichzeitig als Diskette. Also Disketten-Magazin war natürlich immer toll, weil man nicht abtippen musste, da hat man sich im Endeffekt nur eine Diskette gekauft, in so einem Faltblatt, und dann die Beschreibungen waren alle auf Diskette drauf.
Disketten-Magazin, das ist das, was heute Webseite heißt.
Ja, manche Leute machen immer noch Disketten-Magazine, aber es ist inzwischen ein bisschen sinnlos.
Ja, aber im Prinzip ist es genau dasselbe. Der Text war da auch digital drauf.
Digital verteilt der Text.
Gleich mit der Software zum... Also man muss da noch nicht mal runterladen, das war ja sozusagen schon runtergeladen.
Genau, zwei Seiten, zwei mal 170 Kilobyte an reiner Software und vielleicht ein bisschen Text dazu, das das Ganze beschreibt oder halt noch andere Sachen auch beschreibt. Oder das 64er-Magazin, wo man dann die Programme eintippen musste. Und da dann halt auch ein bisschen was davon gekauft. Ich glaube, es war 1990 schon oder Anfang 91, da ist mir eben dann das BASIC auch zu wenig geworden. Da geht man auf Assembler, da muss man sich mal irgendein gutes Buch kaufen, das Assembler vernünftig beibringt. Da habe ich lange nichts gefunden, habe lange nichts verstanden. Und dann ist man eigentlich, das ist eigentlich der kleine Schritt, den man noch machen muss. Und dann macht der Forschertrieb den Rest. Wenn man dann halt die richtige Software hat, so ein Monitor, mit dem man ein bisschen im Speicher rumsuchen kann und seine Programme eintippen kann und ausprobieren kann, oder halt ein richtig schönes Assembler-Programm, das ist halt, schreibe ich als Text und übersetzt und so weiter. Ab dann sind keine Grenzen mehr gesetzt, dann kann man einfach rumprobieren.
Aber was für ein Aha-Erlebnis hast du dann gehabt?
Wie Aha?
Naja, ich unterstelle dir jetzt einfach mal ein Aha-Erlebnis und hinterfrage das.
Was hat das denn du für ein Aha-Erlebnis?
Naja, also wie ich schon sagte, solange ich noch BASIC gemacht habe, war das für mich irgendwie …Ach so, von wegen, ach so geht die Maschine. Ja, genau, das war für mich einfach nicht die Erklärung. Das war mir immer noch alles zu Voodoo und das kann ja jetzt wohl nicht alles gewesen sein. Und in dem Moment, wo man einfach diesen Prozessor direkt programmiert und wirklich die Instruktionen ausführt, die da hinschreibt, die er dann exakt genau ausführt, hole einen Wert aus dem Speicheranadresse sowieso und tu ihn in dein Register A. So, das ist einfach das normale LDA. Das war einfach so …Da war mir einfach klar, jetzt bin ich irgendwie auf Prozessorebene angekommen. Jetzt rede ich für dich wieder.
Im Chip gibt es natürlich dann …Man hat schon einen Aha. Erstmal ist das große Aha, ich kann auf einer Kassette ein Spiel abspielen, da kann ich vielleicht die Musik zum Spiel drauf haben. Ja, aber wie das Spiel? Dann erstmal so ein Aha, das geht irgendwie wirklich. Das war ja ganz naiv, als Kind auch, um da ranzugehen und dann Assembler, okay, ein Aha von wegen, ah ja, 64K, so funktioniert das, ja, aber gleichzeitig stellen sich ja gleich wieder die nächste Frage mit, ich schreibe da so den Wert 169 in Speicher und führe den aus und der hat irgendwie eine Bedeutung. Was geht da jetzt vor? Da ist man gleich schon wieder bei der nächsten Fragestellung, die man dann eigentlich lange nicht beantworten kann. Die Chips bleiben immer noch eine Blackbox, man weiß, was sie tun, aber nicht, wie kann das sein. Das ist doch immer noch dann magisch, da muss man dann nochmal sehr weit gehen.
Na gut, klar, ich meine, man muss natürlich auch erstmal verstehen, was dieses Assembler dann irgendwie tut. Im Falle von 6402, 6502 ist das halt, kann man mal festhalten, es gibt halt drei Register, A, X, Y und ja, das sind sozusagen die drei Bites, die dieser Prozessor gleichzeitig vorhalten kann und mehr halt nicht. So und alles andere liegt eben im RAM und wenn man jetzt mit Daten irgendwas tun will, dann muss man sie halt die ganze Zeit aus dem RAM herausholen, kann sie dann in der CPU ja durchaddieren und durchsubtragieren, von Multiplikation war damals ja auch noch nichts zu sehen und wieder irgendwo hinschreiben und das ist es ja im Wesentlichen. So und dann, in Abhängigkeit von diesen ganzen Operationen, kann man halt irgendwie Tests durchführen, war das jetzt irgendwie eine Null, gab es einen Überlauf, et cetera und da, das ist sozusagen die Mechanik dieser CPU und wie auch immer, also natürlich könnte man jetzt auch noch auf Chip-Ebene auch noch wollen, wollte ich jetzt in dem Sinne nicht. Trotz alledem war das im Vergleich zu diesen BASIC-Kennnissen eine ganz andere Sache, weil ich auf einmal das Gefühl hatte, ich stehe zumindest so mit der Maschine jetzt auf gleicher Augenhöhe.
Ja vor allem, wenn man dann an der Stelle, kann man dann verstehen, wie denn das BASIC selbst implementiert wurde. Denn das BASIC ist ja auch nur Code, der in Assembler geschrieben wurde und der dann einfach halt die Eingaben sich anschaut, ein bisschen transformiert und dann da rein nach halt durchgeht, was will er jetzt eigentlich sagen, da steht ein Print, ja ok, dann schaue ich mal was dahinter steht und so weiter. Und das war ja so die Zeit der ROM-Listings, wo man sich auch Bücher kaufen konnte, wo einfach das komplette ROM, also die 16 Kilobyte komplett ausgedruckt waren, disassembliert in echt einen schönen Assembler-Code und dann kommentiert, stand dann dahinter, was macht das, was ist die Bedeutung? Und dann liest man sich das durch und dann ist das BASIC eigentlich auch komplett desillusioniert, ist man da in Bezug auf das BASIC, weil bisher war man immer so der Sklave vom BASIC, der BASIC macht was, oder man macht was und die BASIC-Götter müssen besänftigt werden und dann plötzlich, ja so schaut der Interpreter aus, das ist ja auch ein Code, das kann ich ja auch, genau.
Schon damals gewusst hätte, dass ich da die Microsoft entkommen bin.
Ja, das ist ja auch ganz lustig mit dieser Microsoft-Sache, da haben wir vorher gar nicht geredet. Microsoft war ein bisschen nicht so glücklich darüber, dass Commodore das nicht gesagt hat, dass es bei Microsoft ist. Die haben das lizenziert, also Microsoft wollte erst mal, für jede verkaufte Version wollten sie Geld. Da werden sie schon mal schön reich geworden, sind sie anderweitig dann ja auch. Commodore hat gesagt, nee, wir zahlen so und so viel, ich weiß nicht, ich zahle jetzt gar nicht mehr und wir wollen das halt auf Lebenszeit benutzen. Und das haben sie beim ersten PET 1977 schon eingebaut, dann beim VC20, C64, die komplette Reihe hat eben dieses BASIC gekriegt. Und bei einer, einmal sind sie zurück zu Microsoft und haben gesagt, Leute, ihr habt hier diese 12 Bugs drin, die müsst ihr fixen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie dann nochmal gezahlt haben, dann haben sie eine neue Version gekriegt und es gibt so einen PET in einer Version, da hat Microsoft ein Ostereien gebaut. Nämlich, wenn du ein Tipps, es gibt den Wait-Befehl, damit kannst du auf einen IOPort warten, bis irgendwie was passiert. Und wenn du da tippst, wait 6502, und dann irgendeine Zahl, dann schreibt der Microsoft auf den Bildschirm. Und Commodore hat das nicht gesehen, Microsoft hat das super schön versteckt und die haben echt halt tausende von diesen PETs in der zweiten Version geschippt, wo man das dann eintippen konnte und das hat dann so funktioniert. Und sie waren halt schon sehr sauer darüber, dass Microsoft das gemacht hat. Vor allem, wenn man halt nur so 8 Kilo Byte, 16 Kilo Byte an Speicher hatte, an ROM-Speicher hatte und die haben dann einfach mal 40 Byte oder sowas verschwendet. Das ging ja gar nicht. Und die haben das wirklich sehr schön kodiert, also die haben den Text halt verschlüsselt, abgelegt und den Code auch so geschrieben, dass es jetzt nicht direkt auffällt. Auch wenn jemand so ein ROM-Listing sich anschaut.
Aber immerhin haben sie sich da nicht übers Ohr hauen lassen, da von Microsoft. Das ist doch auch schon mal ganz schön.
Ja, für der Amiga hat ja auch Microsoft BASIC. Und für den Amiga und dann später auch den C128, da haben sie dann wirklich hingeschrieben Copyright Microsoft, dann haben sie sich da dann geeinigt, wie nur Lizenz.
Microsoft Ausrufezeichen haben sie so, ja?
Ja, Achtzeichen muss das sein.
Auch schöne Rache. Ja, also die Maschine verstehen. Vielleicht, ich meine, die 6502 CPU ist jetzt nicht besonders komplex. Vielleicht kann man auch einfach noch mal so ein bisschen reinschauen. Weil Assembler ist halt, also ich meine, das ist ein normaler Programmcode, den kann man eigentlich immer noch irgendwie erklären. Es gibt zwar auch so Poemin-Sprachen, die machen das auch noch so ein bisschen schwerer, aber so C und Java und so.
Schaut ein bisschen aus wie Englisch.
BASIC, ja genau, ist immer so ein bisschen humanifiziert. Aber Assembler ist immer feindlich, ist immer...
Genau, drei komische Buchstaben und eine Zahl. Dann noch mal drei komische Buchstaben und wieder eine Zahl.
Wenn der Terminator, also Arnold Schwarzenegger in dem ersten Terminator-Film lief irgendwie durch die Straßen und dann hatte er dann auch so ein Display und dann zeigte der Film halt ab und zu mal so, was er so sieht und dann lief er immer so Programmcode über den Bildschirm und da saß ich im Kino und dachte auch nur so, Alter, das ist ja 65002.
Ich frage mich, wie viele Leute diese Erleuchtung hatten. Also da haben viele Leute für sich selbst diese Erleuchtung gehabt, haben dann im Kino den neben sich angestopft und der, hä, wie, was meinst du, 65, weißt du?
Ich hab's genau gesehen, das war irgendwie so LDA, STA, krass.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab's noch mal vom Fernsehen aufgenommen und dann halt so Standbild und so. Ich wollte versuchen, das zu lesen, aber es war halt alles so unfassbar.
Ich stell mir vor, der Terminator wäre wirklich bei 6502 angetrieben geworden.
Das kommt immer auf die Taktung drauf an. Er ist Turing vollständig, du kannst alles drauf laufen lassen.
Das stimmt auch. Vielleicht war das einfach so ein advances Modell, was dann einfach schon so mit mehreren Tirahertz bis fangen wurde.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie komplex der ist und was man heutzutage machen könnte mit diesem Design. Also da haben ja ein paar Jungs den zerlegt, den Chip komplett abgemalt und dann die Transistoren einzeln digitalisiert quasi und können den jetzt simulieren. Das ist das Visual 6502 Projekt, visual6502.org. Die haben rausgefunden, der besteht aus 3510 Transistoren. Mehr nicht. Wenn man genau diese 3510 Transistoren irgendwie wieder in einen neuen Chip...
Wie viele?
3510.
3510 Transistoren?
Nichts mit so viel 1000, sondern 3510. Ein paar davon sind sogar doppelt vom Layout her. Also 3200 ungefähr ist das, was man wirklich braucht, um diese CPU zu bauen. Das ist halt wirklich im Endeffekt trivial. Auch die CPU, wenn man sie dann mal so als Chip-Diagramm sieht, dann kann man die auch verstehen, wenn man ein bisschen genauer hinschaut. Und es macht auch ein wunderschönes Prüster, wenn man sich das gedruckt.
In JavaScript?
Ja, es ist ungefähr ein Faktor Millionen langsamer als das Original, weil die halt wirklich die Physik dahinter simuliert. Der schaut sich halt jetzt da so ein Trace an und legt dann auch eine gewisse Spannung und schaltet dann die Transistoren und schaut dann, was wieder dahinter steckt und so weiter.
Aber der emuliert sozusagen auch alle Fehler und alle Sonderheiten mit.
Also mit dem kann man dann einfach noch in die CPU hineinforschen. Das ist das, was ich vorher meinte. Ja, dann weiß man immer noch nicht, wie die CPU funktioniert, selbst wenn man es verstanden hat. Mit dem weiß man jetzt, warum die CPU genau das macht oder wie so eine CPU an sich funktioniert. Wie kann die so ein Programm ausführen?
Das ist ja cool.
Kamtest du gar nicht?
Okay, da kann ich auch noch was lernen.
Du kannst auch reinzoomen und so und kannst dir Sachen genauer anschauen, wo das da hin und her hüpft und Single-Stappen. Leider kann man die Simulation halt auch heute noch nicht in Echtzeit machen, wenn man das auf physikalischer Ebene macht.
Weil die Maschinen hier noch nicht schnell genug sind. Man muss ja nicht unbedingt den JavaScript machen.
Ja, ich habe das Programm in C nachgeschrieben und bin tausendmal schneller als das JavaScript. Aber ich bin immer noch tausendmal langsamer als Original. Und auf der Ebene, das zu simulieren, kriegt man es auch nicht schneller. Man könnte da jetzt wieder Gates und sowas, man könnte ein paar Sachen wieder rekonstruieren. Aber direkt auf Transistor-Ebene wird man es nicht viel schneller kriegen.
Warum hast du das nicht in Assembler geschrieben?
Ich habe gesagt, diese Wette laufen mit jemand aus unserem Team, der meinte, wenn du es in Assembler schreibst, dann kriegst du es bestimmt schneller. Und er meinte, nein, wirklich nicht. Heutzutage tut man das nicht mehr, außer wirklich an den Stellen, wo C das nicht kann. Aber um Sachen schneller zu machen, die wenigsten Leute können es wirklich noch schneller machen als heutzutage Compiler sind. Und noch habe ich die Wette nicht verloren. Also auf jeden Fall diese ungefähr 3000 Transistoren, wenn man schaut, ein aktueller Core i7 von Intel, der hat ungefähr eine Milliarde. Das heißt, so ein 6502 würde da 300.000 Mal reinpassen. Vielleicht hatte ja so ein Terminator jetzt nicht nur eine 6502, sondern ein paar Millionen von denen, die alle zusammenarbeiten. Und dann alle natürlich mit einem Gigahertz laufen. Oder mit einem Terrahertz.
Kann gut sein. Kann gut sein.
Das wird es gewesen sein.
Ja, auf jeden Fall eine Advanced-Maschine dieser Terminator. Das ist wirklich schick, aber das ist jetzt wirklich ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür, dass hier die Komplexität noch erfahrbar ist. Weil ich blicke ja hier sozusagen auf den vollständigen Chip, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Das kann man sich so vorstellen. Stell dir vor, du hast ein DIN A4-Blatt, so ein kariertes, so mit einem halben Zentimeter Karo. Und in jedes von diesen Karo-Kästchen setzt du einfach einen ganz normalen Transistor rein, den du halt vom Elektronikladen kaufen kannst. Und dann verbindest du die Transistoren miteinander. Das ist genau die Komplexität von 6502. Ach, das ist so... Das ist noch fassbar.
Warte mal, wie viel ist denn das? Du redest von einem halben Zentimeter, also...
Das rechnest du jetzt nach.
Ja.
Du glaubst mir nicht.
Ich komme ja auf 1764, wenn es ein halber Zentimeter ist.
Was? 21 mal 29 mal 4. Dann habe ich mich um ein Faktor 2 verrechnet. Dann brachte man DIN A 3 platt.
Wie auch immer. Aber das ist natürlich eine überschaubare Komplexität.
Dann macht man das nochmal für den Videocontroller. Der ist ein bisschen größer. Sound-Controller ist ungefähr gleich groß. Die zwei Interface-Controllers sind sehr viel weniger komplex. Und dann hat man auf ein paar DIN-A4-Blättern eigentlich wirklich alles, was einem innenen Leben darin passiert. Also noch nicht, dass man das jetzt in der Darstellung verstehen könnte. Aber zumindest ist das alles da. Und dafür ist er schon sehr mächtig. Und das ist eigentlich das Schöne, dass man eben mit geringsten Ressourcen das Maximale rausgeholt hat.
Das lässt mich überhaupt nicht los hier.
Also die Jungs, die das gemacht haben, mit denen arbeite ich auch ein bisschen zusammen, die zerlegen jetzt noch weitere Chips. Die arbeiten gerade an dem Z80 und auch einen 68000, der aus dem Amiga und aus dem Atari und aus dem Macintosh.
Der heißt ja wirklich so, weil er 68000 Transistoren hat, oder?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das war nur Zufall, weil der Vorgänger davon, die 8-Bit-Version, hieß er 68100. Genau, und so ungefähr 68000 Transistoren waren es dann auch. Das können wir bald mal nachzählen, wenn wir den komplett nachgemalt haben. Das wird aber noch ein bisschen dauern. Da haben schon so zwei Leute drei Monate dran gezeichnet. Also halt, was die gemacht haben, ist den Chip mit Säure aufgemacht. Das ist heutzutage sehr in Mode, das macht man hin und wieder auch so bei Chipkartenhacking. Gut fotografiert, mit einem guten Mikroskop. Dann noch mal die ganzen Layer weggeätzt, damit man auf die unterste Ebene kommt, noch mal fotografiert, die zwei Bilder übereinander gelegt und mit so einem Programm, das der da geschrieben hat, einfach die Vektoren nachgezeichnet. Einfach, das sieht man halt, die verschiedenen Schichten und die dann in unterschiedlichen Farben nachgezeichnet. Und dann hat man eine Darstellung, wo man dann sehen kann, wo überlappen sich jetzt die verschiedenen Ebenen. Ah, das muss ein Transistor sein. Dann lässt sich das simulieren.
Wie viele Schichten hat denn so der 6502?
Wenn du mal da runter fährst, die kannst du alle ein- und ausschalten da unten.
Ah, das ist die hier? Also hatte er sechs oder was?
Tja, das ist auch die Stelle, wo ich mich inzwischen noch nicht auskenne, wo ich auch noch lernen will.
Einen habe ich hier noch vergessen, also sechs, sieben verschiedene Layer. Schon ganz schön komplex. Jetzt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, drunter und drüber. Na, aber jetzt erklär doch mal den Prozessor.
Den Prozessor? Von was kann man denn ausgehen, dass man schon ein Grundwissen hat?
Na ja, man erklärt halt einfach gut.
Okay, so dass es auch meine Mama erklären, verstehen würde, so heißt es. Ja, also da hat man so eine CPU, die ja sequenziellen Programme ausführt. Immer so eine Assembler-Instruktion, Next-Assembler-Instruktion, einfach mal so da rein nach. Und so eine Assembler-Instruktion, wenn ich die jetzt mal so als Bytes anschaue, dann ist die mal ein Byte, zwei Byte oder drei Byte lang. Aber dann schaut ein Programm irgendwie aus wie A9-008D20D060. Das ist nicht besonders lesbar, aber das sind im Endeffekt die Bits, die da so in die CPU reingehen. Deswegen gibt es, das wäre die Maschinensprache, der Maschinencode. Aber ich will das in Assembler-Darstellung anschauen. Das ist so ein bisschen dekodiert, sodass ein Mensch das ein bisschen besser verstehen kann. Aber es hat halt nichts mit ASCII zu tun. Also im Grunde, ich schreibe es in ASCII, aber das wird dann nochmal umgewandelt in eben diese Bitfolgen.
Also was für den Prozessor ein A9 ist, das liest man dann als Programmierer mit LDA. Das ist sozusagen die Übersetzung. Und, weiß nicht, STA zum Absprechen. Was war das? Lass mich raten. 8.5?
8.5 ist 0-Page. Wenn du es nur in die 0-Page schreibst, ist es ein 8.5. Also das ist schön, mit der Zeit lernt man auch die Codierung dann automatisch.
Das ist so einfach gewesen. Irgendwann konnte man sie eigentlich auch weitgehend ausfindig, weil man hat ja dann auch Hex-Code gelesen.
Und es war auch relativ logisch. Also nicht 100% logisch. Andere CPUs sind ein bisschen logischer. Aber das wurde natürlich auch im Chip so optimiert, dass man die Opcodes so gewählt hat, dass der Chip maximal minimal gemacht werden konnte. Also schaue ich mir das Ganze dann von so einer Assembler-Seite an, dann würde das Programm jetzt aussehen wie LDA, Gartenzaun 0, SDA, Dollar, D020. Und es sind immer noch sehr viele Zahlen dabei. Oder RTS dann, das war das, was ich gerade vorher gesagt habe. Und LDA, STA, das sind ja wieder mal nur Abkürzungen. Ich weiß nicht, warum man das eigentlich so macht, dass man das dann nochmal so codiert ablegt, aber es reicht wohl auch.
Ja, man will ja auch nicht so viel Platz verschwenden, wenn man das dann abspeichert als Source-Code, sozusagen, ablegt.
Also professionell wurde sehr viel cross-developed. Das heißt, man hat jetzt das Betriebssystem vom C64 nicht auf dem C64 entwickelt, sondern auf irgendwelchen WEX-Großrechner. Oder auch Microsoft hat das BASIC für 6502 auch auf WEX entwickelt, hat da seine eigenen Assembler und Compiler geschrieben und ist dann halt immer rüber transferiert über irgendwelche komischen Kabel- und Schnittstellen. Oder teilweise auch im Emulator, also Microsoft, weiß ich, die haben einen Emulator geschrieben für den 6502. Damit ist es halt trotzdem sehr viel einfacher zu programmieren auf der Ebene. Brauchst du aber halt eine wirklich 100.000 Dollar teure WEX.
Da gab es ja mal diese schöne Geschichte mit Seymour Cray, der irgendwie erzählt wurde, dass Apple jetzt gerade sich eine Cray gekauft hat, um ihren nächsten Computer zu entwickeln. Oder es ist lustig, ich habe mir auch gerade eine Apple gekauft, um meine nächste Cray zu entwickeln.
Also da ist diese Codierung, LDA zum Beispiel heißt Load Accumulator oder Load A-Register. Also es gibt hier diese drei Register, hast du ja schon gesagt, A, X, Y. Die sind alle drei Byte jeweils groß und da kann ich was reinladen aus dem Speicher oder ich kann von denen was in den Speicher reinschreiben. Und das ist das, was eigentlich die meiste Zeit passiert, dass ich ein Speicher lade, Speicher schreibe, mal was addiere, mal was vergleiche und dann bedingt springe, je nach dem was passiert ist. Und so ein LDA, eben Load Akku, dann STA, Store Akku, damit kann ich ein Speicher schreiben, also gerade das Beispiel von vorhin, LDA, Gartenzaun 0, liest einfach die Immediate Konstante 0 in den Akku rein, das ist gar nicht aus dem Speicher lesen, das ist jetzt wirklich mal eine Konstante ablegen. Ich könnte auch sagen LDA 12345, dann liest er aus der Speicherstelle 12345, wenn ich den Gartenzaun weglasse.
Also Gartenzaun ist dein spezieller Code für das Hash-Zeichen.
Das Hash-Zeichen, wie sagt man das im Deutschen?
Ich weiß nicht, das ist jetzt glaube ich eins dieser Zeichen, was wirklich extrem viele Namen hat. Ich sage mal Lattenzaun.
Lattenzaun?
Ja, ich finde Lattenzaun hat mehr Dynamik als Gartenzaun.
Ja, auch im Englischen hat es ein paar Namen, das ist auch Sharp und Pound.
Jaja, man ist sich überhaupt nicht einig, was die Dinger so heißen.
Doppelkreuz. Shift 3.
Lattenzaun. Oder Gartenzaun.
Also mit den STA Speicher kann ich dann genau den Speicher schreiben. Und ja, was hat man denn nach so? Dann kann ich was addieren. ADC, add with carry. Carry ist ja der Übertrag. Es gibt keinen Addierbefehl ohne Übertrag, es gibt einen mit Übertrag. Das heißt, man muss vorher explizit den Übertrag setzen oder löschen, sonst addiert einem noch eine 1 mit dazu, die man gar nicht haben will. Also im add kann ich nur mit dem A-Register machen. X und Y haben Spezialfunktionen, da kann ich nicht addieren. Das ist auch so ein bisschen die ganzen x86 Leute, die sich mit so was auskennen, die wissen ja auch, x86 hat einen Haufen Spezialregister, da sind zwar 8 Register drin, aber nicht jedes kann alles. Somit, die ganzen RISC und auch ARM und PowerPC und so, die eigentlich moderneren Architekturen, die haben ja einfach diese Massenweise an großen Register zwischen Speichern, wo ich dann auch aus dem Speicher lesen kann und im Speicher schreiben kann, aber ich kann auch mit jedem einzelnen Register rechnen.
Das ging halt hier überhaupt nicht, sondern...
Addiere doch mal Register 5 zu Register 7.
Eigentlich gibt es nur diesen 1000-Sasser, das ist das A, das kann so eigentlich alles, das ist sozusagen der Inbegriff der eigentlichen CPU und alles, was die CPU macht, macht sie mit einem einzigen 8-Bit-Wert.
Die allermeisten Daten gehen da durch.
Genau, und selbst wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, so ein 16-Bit-Wert errechnen will, dann muss man erstmal die zwei 8-Bit-Low-Komponenten sozusagen zusammennehmen, man addiert sie zusammen, dann hat man sozusagen das Ergebnis, das kann man dann irgendwie wegschreiben, und wie dann eben bei der normalen Papierrechnung, nicht wahr, wenn man so über 10 gekommen ist, dann hat man halt eins im Sinn, und dieses eins im Sinn ist halt dann dieses Carry-Bit, das heißt also da sind dann neben diesem Akku und dem X und dem Y, wenn wir vielleicht noch gleich kommen, gibt es dann noch so eine ganze Batterie von Flags, von so Zuständen, die sich der Prozessor immer irgendwie merkt und die dann bei der nächsten Durchführung einer Addition zum Beispiel wieder eine Rolle spielen.
Das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, kann man ja direkt auch gleich in ein Ensembler-Programm übersetzen. Also wenn ich jetzt zwei Zahlen im Speicher stehen habe, die eine steht bei 10 und 11 im Speicher und die andere bei 12 und 13, das ist halt eine 16-Bit-Zahl und deswegen muss ich halt jeweils zwei Byte verbrauchen, dann lese ich zuerst die 10, also LDA 10, ich lese aus dem Speicher aus der Stelle 10, muss dann meinen Carry, meinen Übertrag mal löschen, weil ich will ja nicht, dass noch eine 1 dazugezählt wird, also CLC, Clear Carry, der dritte Befehl dann ADC 12, Add with Carry, aus der Speicherstelle 12, das ist die untere Hälfte von dem zweiten Wert und dann STA, da muss ich ihn irgendwo hinlegen, weil sonst geht er ja verloren, wenn ich das nächste Mal was in Akku lese, dann schreiben wir mal zu 14, STA 14, also 14,15 wäre dann unser Ergebnis und dann habe ich in meinem Überlauf, in meinem Carry-Flag steht, ob es dann Übertrag gegeben hat. Also ich kann ja nur bis 255 zählen, wenn die zwei Zahlen zusammen mehr als 255 ergeben haben, habe ich ja nur den Rest im Grunde und dann müsste ich noch 256 dazuzählen und das steht in meinem Carry.
Also Carry ist sozusagen das neunte Bit.
Und dann nehme ich meine zwei oberen und addiere die zusammen. Das heißt, ich mache LDA 11, das ist die obere Hälfte vom ersten, und mache ADC, also ein Add wieder mit Carry, das wäre dann die 13, also die obere Hälfte vom zweiten Wert. Und jetzt sind das Carry gleich mit dazu addiert, ob ich eben einen Überlauf hatte von der unteren Hälfte und dann speichere ich das nach STA 15. Und dann steht in 14,15, steht dann mein 16-Bit-Wert. Das heißt, ja, alles, was über 8-Bit geht, wird dann ziemlich kompliziert, muss ich dann echt bei Hand machen. Da versteht man dann auch ein bisschen die ganze Binärlogik dahinter ein bisschen besser, wenn man sich damit ja explizit auseinandersetzen muss.
Das versteht man auch, warum man irgendwie sehr froh war, als man dann endlich auf 16-Bit und 32-Bit und jetzt auch 64-Bit-Computing kam.
Bei 64-Bit braucht man das ganz, ganz selten. Da kann man ja zählen bis...
Viel.
32-Bit waren es ja schon 4 Milliarden.
Wobei, ich glaube, auch die 64-Bit-Maschinen auch intern dann auch mit mal 128-Bit schon rechnen können und das dann selber hin und her schieben, oder?
Wie?
Da kann man eigentlich auch mehrere Register zusammenfassen und da gemeinsam drauf rumrechnen.
Ach ja, die Multiplikation vom x86. Da kannst du auch zwei Register zusammenzählen. Dann rechne ich mit 128 jetzt die aktuellen.
Genau, also die Zeiten sind so ein bisschen vorbei, aber das ist halt genau das Ding. Und jetzt haben wir, ähm, hast du im Kopf, wie viele Instruktionen das jetzt irgendwie waren? Also Clear Carry, Laden, was weiß ich, 10, 15?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
7 Schritte. Und weißt du auch noch, wie schnell die sind?
Jede einzelne von denen hier hat genau zwei Taktik gebraucht. Das sind die, ähm, die, nein, also die, die L, also die, die, das, nein, stimmt gar nicht. Also, das Lesen aus dem, aus dem Speicher, das kommt darauf an, da gibt es auch eine sehr tolle Optimierung. Ähm, wenn ich aus dem Speicher lese, brauche ich normalerweise vier Takte. Also wenn ich mit dem Megahertz laufe, dann heißt das, dass ich 250.000 Mal pro Sekunde kann ich aus dem Speicher lesen. Also so ein LDA, das ist nicht so, dass jetzt ein Takt heißt, eine Instruktion kann ich ausführen.
250.000 Mal aus dem Speicher?
Mal vier, bei vier Zyklen. 250.000 Mal vier, eine Million. Ähm, also ein Megahertz, eine Million Instruktionen pro Sekunde, heißt halt nicht wirklich Instruktionen pro Sekunde, sondern eben Takte pro Sekunde. Instruktionen brauchen mehr als einen Takt. Das ist bei den unterschiedlichen CPUs auch total anders.
Also manche brauchen auch nur einen.
Nein, einen gibt es nicht. Doch. Nein. NOP braucht zwei.
Bitte?
Deswegen hat dein Code nie funktioniert. NOP, no operation.
Echt?
Der tut nichts. Der überspringt eben nur den Befehl. Das ist, wenn man mal was patchen will. Wenn man kodgeschrieben und dann gesehen hat, ja, da ist jetzt ein Loch drin, das will man eigentlich gar nicht, dann haut man sich ein NOP rein. Codierung EA 234. Und der hat...
Echt, der hat zwei?
Der braucht zwei. Zwei ist das kleinste, kleiner geht nicht. Und eben mit diesem Visual 64 LV2, wenn man sich das mal durchsingelstappt, dann kann man das auch verstehen, wieso. Weiß ich nicht.
Tatsache, zwei. Du meinst, weil einfach sozusagen, also er kann gar nichts in einem Schritt machen. Sondern man muss einfach mindestens zwei Schritte haben und auch das Nichtstun dauert zwei Schritte. Stimmt, zwei. Da hatte ich irgendwie anders in Erinnerung. Das heißt, wie lange dauert jetzt unser Programm, zwei Zahlen aus dem Speicher zu addieren und das wieder im Speicher abzulegen, 16 Bit?
Drei plus zwei plus drei, rechne mal mit. Also das erste Lesen braucht drei. Also normalerweise aus dem Speicher lesen braucht vier. Aber wenn ich aus den unteren 256 Byte vom Speicher lese, der sogenannten Zero-Page, dann geht es schneller. Genau, weil nämlich dann meine Codierung viel einfacher ist. Dann hat nämlich der LDA-Befehl, wir stehen nur aus zwei Byte, nämlich aus dem Code für LDA Zero-Page und eben diesen Byte, was die Adresse ist, aus der ich lesen will. Und wenn ich normalerweise aus dem Speicher lese, dann habe ich eine andere Codierung für LDA. Also das ist hier der Unterschied zwischen AD und A5. A5 wäre aus der Zero-Page lesen, AD heißt normal lesen. Und mit dem nicht Zero-Page muss ich dann eben eine komplette 16-Bit-Adresse ablegen und der Befehl ist 3 Byte lang. Und es ist so überschlagen, kann man das Ganze immer so viel Byte, wie die Instruktion ist, so viel Zyklen braucht es. Also Minimum und dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen was dazu, wenn es ein bisschen komplexer wird von dem, was ich mache. Im Beispiel haben wir ja Adressen kleiner 256 gehabt, deswegen braucht jetzt das Laden 3 Zyklen. Das Clear Carry braucht zwei, das tut nicht viel, aber es braucht immer mindestens zwei. Das Addieren drauf, das ist auch wieder ein Speicherzugriff. Das Addieren kostet nichts, weil die Alu sitzt da und die macht was.
Also Alu ist die arithmetische logische Einheit?
Genau, die Alu ist ein Teil von der CPU, die dann das eigentliche Rechnen macht. Und die kann innerhalb von einem Zyklus einfach rechnen, was immer langsam ist. In jeder CPU sind immer die Speicherzugriffe. Und allein der Befehl selbst hat ja schon mal die Speicherzugriffe, dass der Befehl überhaupt aus dem Speicher gelesen wird. Wenn ich jetzt so ein LDA von dieser Stelle sehe...
Also deswegen wahrscheinlich auch zwei Cycles.
Der NOP hat aber nur einen. Der NOP hat nur einen Byte, aber eben zwei Cycles.
Na gut, erstmal muss er gelesen werden und dann muss er nichts tun.
Ja, stimmt, im Grunde. Ja, wenn ich jetzt so nachdenke, im ersten wird er gelesen und im zweiten wird was ausgeführt. Also wird decodiert und dann das getan, was getan werden soll.
Nämlich nichts.
Nichts und das dauert dann wahrscheinlich seinen Zyklus sehr.
Ja, dass nichts tun. Dauert. Was jeder bestätigen kann, der auf seinem Sofa sitzt und gerade nichts tut.
Also haben wir drei und für das Clear Carry nochmal zwei. Für das Laden oder für das Addieren, also Speicherlesen. Speicherlesen ist langsam, dauert auch wieder drei. Sind wir schon bei acht. Dann wegspeichern, wieder drei, sind wir bei elf. Dann lese ich das Low-Byte vom zweiten, nochmal drei. Dann brauche ich ja mit dem Carry nichts machen, sondern ich lese oder ich addiere das andere High-Byte drauf, nochmal drei. Und wieder wegspeichern, nochmal drei. Sollen wir auf?
Zwanzig.
Zwanzig. Das heißt, wie viel 16-Bit-Additionen kann ich machen pro Sekunde?
Zwanzig Takte und dann müssen wir halt einfach die... Fünfzigtausend.
Fünfzigtausend solche Additionen. Da kann man sich jetzt ganz konkret mal überlegen, wie lange dauert es, den Bildschirm zu löschen.
Also hätten wir jetzt im Speicher gemacht, dann wäre es...
Ja, aber sowas macht man immer in der Zero-Page. Also solche Sachen. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Sichtweisen, wie man es sehen kann. Du hast beschrieben, wir haben drei Register A, X, Y. Andere Leute könnten sagen, wir haben 256 Register.
Ah, verstehe.
Ich nehme nämlich die Zero-Page. Weil immer, wenn... Im Endeffekt, du musst fast alles durch ein Akku durchschieben. Aber weil du eben immer mit Speicher arbeiten musst, dann nimmst du einfach immer die Zero-Page her, auch als Zwischenspeicher. Die ist langsamer als der Akku, ist aber schneller als normaler Speicher. Ist eigentlich so eine Art Cache fast.
Aber trotzdem wurde er beim C64 nicht nur frei... Also wurde er jetzt nicht freigehalten, nur für solche arithmetischen Operationen. Sondern in der Zero-Page standen ja, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, so allerlei wichtige Grundeinstellungen.
Ja, sowohl das Betriebssystem, also diese Kernel, als auch BASIC hatten da drin eben auch ihre wichtigen Sachen drin. Weil die ja auch schnell sein wollten. Und dann war gar nicht mehr so viel byte-frei. Interessanterweise die Adresse 2, die war frei. Die haben sie irgendwie vergessen. Die haben nämlich bei 3 angefangen, erst wieder mit Sachen. 0 und 1 sind eh belegt mit diesem IOPort, um Speicher umzuschalten. Und ich glaube ganz oben FDF, EFF, da konnte man noch. Und dann zwischendurch, je nachdem, was man halt gerade nicht gebraucht hat, weil da war halt mal so ein Flag wie, was ist eigentlich der Status von der letzten Diskette-Operation? Und naja gut, wenn ich gerade nichts mit Diskette mache, kann ich ja jederzeit in die Adresse 90 reinschreiben.
Aber ich denke, das war jetzt so ein bisschen ein Marsch, aber ich denke, das macht eigentlich klar, was die CPU nun eigentlich tatsächlich tut. Und vor allem, wie lange das dauert. Wenn man sich das jetzt mal vorstellt, also 50.000 Mal kann man in einer Sekunde addieren. Und man will dann ein Spiel programmieren, was alle möglichen Dinge tut, was vielleicht in dieser Sekunde zweimal auf meine Joystick-Bewegung reagiert. Irgendwelches Breiz knattert über in den Bildschirm. Der Sound-Interface-Chip will die ganze Zeit mit Musikinformationen versorgt werden, damit es auch im Hintergrund ordentlich dudelt und immer schön Krachbumm macht, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas abgeschossen habe. Und dazu will man dann vielleicht auch noch grafisch irgendwie dabei sein und braucht auch noch so ein bisschen Logik, um das Ziel dieses Spieles auch permanent zu überprüfen.
Das Stichwort an der Stelle ist ja Rasterzeit. Weil alles, was man so in einem Spiel jetzt machen will, oder auch in einem Demo, aber normalerweise halt in Spielen, muss man ja immer irgendwie synchronisieren mit dem Bildschirmaufbau. Denn während gerade, also, sollen wir da mal in Richtung Fernsehtechnik gehen?
Ja, bitte.
Somit, ja, 50 Mal pro Sekunde auf einem PAL oder auf einem NTSC halt dann 60 Mal pro Sekunde wird der Bildschirm wirklich neu aufgebaut. Das heißt, der Videochip liest den Bildschirmspeicher aus oder liest halt Speicher aus und baut sich da seine Pixel zusammen und schickt ein analoges Signal an Fernseher. Das ist dann wirklich 50 Mal pro Sekunde refreshed. Also immer wieder, dasselbe ist. Du wirst keine Diffs oder Deltas rübergeschickt, sondern immer wieder das komplette Bild. Und während der Videocontroller aus dem Speicher liest, um seine Pixel darzustellen, kann die CPU schon auch normal mit Speicher umgehen, weil die teilen sich den Speicher ja sehr schön. Aber man sollte immer nur dann den Videospiecher verändern, wenn gerade er in der Vertical Blank-Area ist. Das heißt, er malt immer 200 Zeilen und dann tut er für 112 Zeilen nichts, weil der Strahl wieder nach oben fahren muss. Oder er erst mal ein paar leere Zeilen malt und dann fährt er wieder nach oben. Wenn man in der Zeit den Grafikspeicher ändert, ist das wunderbar. Wenn man es macht, während er gerade aufbaut, dann kriegt man solche Tearing-Artefakte. Weil man nicht genau weiß, wann die CPU gerade das eine macht und der Videochip das andere macht. Dann kriegt man das halbe Bild vom vorherigen Zustand und das halbe vom nachheren Zustand. Das flimmert ganz blöd. Deswegen hat man ja für den Bildaufbau eh schon gar nicht mehr so viel Rasterzeit. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt so 50 Mal pro Sekunde hat, hat man ja diese 312 Zeilen, die PAL hat. Und 200 Zeilen davon, währenddessen sollte man den Bildschirm nicht anfassen. Dann hat man nur noch 112 Zeilen, wo man den Bildschirm anfassen kann. Und das ist dann ja megaherztechnisch auch nur noch, also 200 Kilohertz, die man im Endeffekt da an rechten Zeit hat.
Wobei man jetzt noch dazu sagen sollte, es ist jetzt nicht nur so der reine Bildschirm selbst, also nicht alles, was der Fernseher darstellen kann oder der Monitor, sondern C64 hatte ja seine Kernanzeigefläche nochmal von einem Rahmen umgeben. Also es gab sozusagen die eigentliche adressierbare Grafikbereich, aber der nahm vielleicht nur, weiß nicht, 60 Prozent des eigentlichen Bildschirmfläche ein.
Ja, schon ein bisschen mehr oder? Bei NTSC sogar noch ein bisschen mehr, weil NTSC hatte nicht so viele Zeilen. Die haben ja nur, glaube ich, 240, 250 Zeilen oder so, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Ich lasse es 70 Prozent sein, aber auf jeden Fall, es wird einiges verloren. Aber es wird natürlich auch was gewonnen, weil selbst wenn dieser Raster quasi schon im sichtbaren Bereich des Bildschirms ist, ist er unter Umständen noch damit beschäftigt, diesen Rahmen zu malen, bevor dann der eigentliche Inhalt des C64-Video beginnt und dann unten wieder Rahmen, sodass man ja mehr Zeit hatte eigentlich, mehr Rasterzeit.
Also es war halt so eine Timing-Frage damals, wo man das designt hat, wie man das mit den Pixeln so macht. Wenn man jetzt ein PAL-System hat, hat man halt so seine 112 theoretische Zeilen sichtbar davon, so um die 270, 280. Das ist immer dieses Overscan-Problem am Fernseher. Das hat man heutzutage auch immer noch, wenn man eine Spielekonsole zum ersten Mal anschließt. Ist das auch immer so mit, wie viel siehst du eigentlich gerade noch, sodass ich da auch noch die Menüs reinmachen kann, weil Fernseher ja immer, je nachdem, wie hinten das Rädchen gedreht ist und im Digitalen heutzutage teilweise auch noch, oder halt absichtlich, um kompatibel zu sein, werden halt einen Haufen Pixel von links, rechts, oben, unten abgeschnitten. Und deswegen einen Haufen von diesen eigentlich darstellbaren Pixel, kann man eh schon mal nicht verwenden, weil manche Fernseher die dann abgeschnitten hätten. Deswegen wurde es schon mal kleiner. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt sagst, sichtbare Bildschirmfläche ist ja so viel weniger, vielleicht hattest du einfach einen Fernseher, der sehr wenig Overscan hatte. Das heißt, bei dir hat der Rahmen sehr viel größer ausgesehen. Also jetzt eventuell bei anderen Leuten. Also wie viel in den Rahmen man da noch gehen hätte können, wäre halt so die Frage gewesen. Und da hat man sich halt damals auf so einen Kompromiss geeinigt. Wir machen jetzt 200 Zeilen, weil das passt halt einfach von der Mathematik her sehr schön. Gerade mit diesen 320 passt das schön zusammen. Dann ist halt oben und unten ein bisschen Rahmen noch, den man nicht verwenden kann. Links und rechts war gar nicht so viel. Weil das sind diese 320 Pixel, sehr viel weiter kann man horizontal eh nicht gehen. Jetzt kommt deine Geschichte, oder?
Man kann ja erstmal so ein bisschen erklären, was... Also ich meine, der C64 hatte ja so eine spezielle Fähigkeit in Bezug auf diesen Raster, indem er in der Lage war, dem Programm auch zu sagen, wo sich denn der Rasterstrahl gerade befindet.
Genau.
Das muss ich gerade nochmal ein bisschen nachdenken, aber du kannst es einfach mal erklären.
Also der VEC, der Videocontroller, der ist im Speicher auch adressierbar, als wäre es ein normaler Speicher. Also im Adressraum sitzt er einfach rum. Der sitzt an der Adresse HEX jetzt D000. Und der hat da ein paar Register, also 32 Register, die letzten paar sind nicht belegt. Und da kann ich ein paar Sachen, also zum Beispiel, wenn ich einen Sprite einschalten will, dann muss ich da halt einfach ein Wert reinschreiben. Also die bekannten Peaks und Pokes von BASIC. Wenn ich da einen Poke mache, dann kann ich einem Videocontroller jetzt sagen, mach doch mal einen Sprite an oder so.
Peaks und Pokes sind einfach die BASICs-Commandos zum Lesen und Schreiben von Speicher direkt.
Genau, aber es muss nicht nur Speicher sein, also halt Schreiben von in den Adressbereich.
Dahinter ist dann entweder Speicher oder eben, je nachdem wie diese Bank umgeschaltet wurde beim Prozessor, dann direkt die Register des entsprechenden Chips.
Genau, und da mach ich einen Poke, dann schreib ich in so einen Chip rein. Oder von Assembler mach ich halt einen STA an diese Adresse. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel D020, da ist die Rahmenfarbe. 16 Farben, das haben wir übrigens noch gar nicht gesagt. 16 fest installierte Farben, es gibt keine Palette, aber die Farben sind sehr schön. Ja, gefallen mir auch sehr. Ich hab vor kurzem mal meinen Editor auf dem Mac umgestellt, auf diese Farben. Ist schon angenehm. Dieses Blau auf Blau, Hellblau, Dunkelblau. 16 und 16, die zwei Farben.
Hatte was Beruhigendes.
Ja, jeder Computer von Commodore hatte auch so sein eigenes Farbschema.
Ach echt?
Die Pets, die waren, ja, klassisches Grün auf Schwarz. Der Plus-4, der war schwarz auf weiß, aber mit hellblauem Rahmen. Der C128 war hellgrün auf mittelgrau und mit hellgrünem Rahmen. Oh Gott.
Und dann gab es noch den C128.
Das ist ja nochmal eine ganz eigene Sache. Obwohl, da gibt es gar nicht so viel zu erzählen. Wo waren wir?
Kommen wir noch dazu. Du wolltest gerade die Rahmenfarbe ändern und hast $D020 adressiert.
Genau, da steht die Rahmenfarbe. Dann D021 wäre jetzt die Hintergrundfarbe, die halt dann global pro Seite ist. Meine Zeichenfarben kann ich wieder einzeln ändern.
Das war eigentlich immer das beste Beispiel, um so Leuten klar zu machen, was eigentlich Speicheradressierung bedeutet, weil man ja das eben dann auch wirklich in BASIC direkt so eingeben konnte. Computer einschalten und er sagte ready. Und dann macht man als Erster das POG, 53.280, und dann hat man dann eine entsprechende Farbe gesetzt. Dann änderte sich dann eben auch sofort die Rahmenfarbe. Und 81 war die innere Farbe dann.
53.280 ist Hex D020. Das sind so ein paar Sachen, die man immer noch auswendig weiß. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Ich bin jetzt gerade echt… So eine Zahl bleibt hängen, oder? Genauso wie die 49.152.
Ja, das ist ja auch so eine Eigenschaft von allen Leuten, die was mit Computern zu tun haben, dass sie jederzeit aus dem Stand alles verdoppeln. Also so 124, 16, 234, 16, 28, 26, 25, 25, 124, 124, 2048, das kann man einfach, oder?
Wie weit kannst du?
4.096, 8.001, 2.9.0, 16.384, 32.760, 35.536.
Und jetzt wird es schwierig.
Ich bin 16-Bit-Mensch.
Weite könnte ich es auch nicht, 131 irgendwas.
Ja, dann wird es schwammig. Aber das kommt halt irgendwie auch noch aus dieser Zeit. Und da, weiß ich nicht, da war das ja irgendwie täglich Brot. Man musste die ganze Zeit zwischen Dezimal und Hexadezimal umherrechnen. Ja, aber vor allem auch, um das eben mal in BASIC machen zu können. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hatten sie Hexadezimal ja nicht vorgesehen.
Ja, das muss man vielleicht noch sagen. Das BASIC, das im C64 war, das war zu der Zeit auch schon ein bisschen alt. Microsoft hatte das 76 geschrieben und ja, das war ja schon sechs Jahre alt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und Commodore hatte auch schon eine verbesserte Version, die in den größeren Pads war, die drin. Aber für den C64 hat man dann die ganzen Features wieder rausgenommen, weil man eben einen kleinen Romtrip haben wollte. Commodore hätte ein besseres BASIC gehabt. Haben sie aber nicht eingebaut, aus Kostengründen.
Haben sie auch letztendlich nicht gebraucht. Sie haben die Leute damit eigentlich nur ins Assembler getrieben und gezwungen, gute Programme zu machen.
Ja, auch deswegen, also schneller machen hätten sie es vor allem auch müssen. Also das BASIC war wirklich unglaublich langsam.
Na gut, aber wir wollen jetzt rein in den Chip und wir wollen vor allem rein in den WIG. Und du wolltest ja dann auf diese Rasterzeilen geschehen, die zu sprechen kommen.
Genau, da gibt es ja diese Register. Und einer davon, D012, ist der, da kann ich immer schauen, welche Zeile vom Bildschirm wird eigentlich gerade gemalt. Und das ist dann wirklich total faszinierend, weil wenn ich da ein Assembler-Programm schreibe, dann bin ich ja quasi so schnell wie gerade der Rasterstrahl. Ich muss ein Programm schreiben, das gerade überprüft, wo jetzt gerade so ein Elektronenstrahl auf dem Bildschirm. Ich meine, der macht das 50 Mal pro Sekunde. Mein Auge sieht das ja gar nicht, dass der da rüber saust. Auch wegen diesem Nachläufeffekt. Aber intern in der Maschine ist es dann doch immer noch so, der saust von oben nach unten. Und ich kann dem Programm abfragen, wo er gerade ist. Um jetzt mal vom Timing her ein bisschen zu sehen, 63 Zyklen ist genau eine Rasterzeile auf PAL. Das sind doch ein paar Instruktionen, die ich machen kann. Der Rasterstrahl ist schon sehr schnell. Aber in der Geschwindigkeit von der CPU ist er eigentlich immer noch langsam. Eine CPU läuft doch deutlich schneller als dieser Rasterstrahl. Dann müsste ich hin und wieder schon ein kleines Programm schreiben, das auf eine gewisse Rasterzeile wartet. Und da kann man dann diverse Tricks machen. Der Standard-Trick, und dafür wurde es auch gemacht, dass man darauf zugreifen kann, wo ich gerade bin. Wieso sollte man wollen, wo das gerade ist, ist das Screensplitting. Da kann man jetzt mal wieder ein Mario-Beispiel machen. Bei den ganzen Jump'n'Run-Spielen hat man oben immer den Spielstand. Wie viel Leben hat man noch, wie viele Punkte hat man, wie viele Diamanten hat man. Und darunter hat man dann das eigentliche Spielfeld, das sagen wir mal von links nach rechts oder rechts nach links scrollt. Aber man will ja, dass die Punkte immer stehen bleiben und nicht mit scrollen. Und das ist einfach der Trick, dass man den Bildschirm in zwei Bereiche aufteilt. Der Videocontroller hat immer nur einen Zustand von diesen Registern. Und wenn der jetzt anfängt, seine Pixel zu malen, hat er einen gewissen Zustand. Und wenn er diesen Status fertig gemalt hat, also wenn er an der Rasterzeile so 20 Zeilen unter dem Bildschirm Anfang ist, dann sage ich dem Videochip einfach, Moment, du bist jetzt ganz anders konfiguriert. Und dann sage ich ihm, ja jetzt ist Scrolling eigentlich abgeschaltet. Oder angeschaltet, wenn ich es für die andere Hälfte haben will. Und dem VWC ist es egal, ab jetzt macht er einfach alles anders. Und wenn ich das oft genug umschalte, kann ich halt einen Haufen interessante Effekte machen. Also zum Beispiel, da gehen jetzt solche Effekte wie das halt, ich glaube das hatten auch ein paar Spiele, dass etwas, was weiter vorne aussieht, schneller scrollt. Das heißt, ich mache halt Screen-Splitting viele viele Male auf dem Bildschirm. Und scrolle halt Sachen, die weiter unten am Bildschirm sind, sehr viel schneller vorbei. Also es gab ein Rambo oder so ein Spiel, das hatte ein dreifaches Screen, ein vierfaches Screen-Splitting. Ich meine, da ist ja wirklich nicht viel dabei. Das kann man recht schnell machen. Oben erstmal eine Statuszeile, dann so ein Hintergrund, wo irgendwelche Wälder ganz langsam gescrollt haben. Und dann ein Standardding, wo ich nach rechts laufe. Und ganz vorne haben sie noch ein bisschen gebüscht, das dann ganz schnell vorbei läuft. Im Grunde geht es in Richtung Parallax-Scrolling. Aber das ist dann eigentlich nur, wenn es sich auch überdeckt. Das ist jetzt ohne Überdecken.
In welche Richtung geht das?
Das ist, wenn du... Im Grunde dieser Effekt, dass du... Also stell dir vor, du hast drei Glasplatten, wo du drei Sachen drauf gemalt hast. Und die hast du übereinander, also halt mit ein paar Zentimeter dazwischen. Und dann wackelst du die so nach links und rechts. Dann siehst du halt, dass die vorderen Sachen sich schneller bewegen als die hinteren. Also kommt eigentlich aus der Zeichentrickfilm-Ecke.
Genau, und wenn ich das richtig erinnere, konnte man ja den, also man könnte nicht nur auslesen, wo er gerade ist, sondern man könnte auch sagen, sag mir Bescheid, wenn du da und da bist.
Genau, also das sind ja die zwei unterschiedlichen Arten, wie ich an sich mit Ereignissen umgehen kann, also mit Input-Output-Sachen, entweder Poling, das heißt, ich schaue die ganze Zeit nach, sind wir schon soweit, sind wir schon soweit, sind wir schon soweit, dann verbrauche ich natürlich die ganze Zeit, weil ich nichts anderes tun kann. Oder halt Türklingel-Prinzip, weck mich auf, oder ich mache jetzt mal, sag es mir, wenn es dann soweit ist. Und dann kann ich dem Videochip sagen, ja, also ich mache jetzt mal meine Musikroutine, oder ich mache jetzt mal Programm Logik, oder ich lade etwas von Floppy nach. Aber wenn du gerade am Anfang vom Bildschirm bist, dann sag es mir. Und dann mit ein bisschen Verzögerung hat man es dann. Und dann kann man auf das Ereignisse reagieren. Und dann sagen, es ist halt ein Interrupt, man ist in einer Interrupt-Routine, und dann sagt man Schluss, Return from Interrupt, RTE, die Instruktion, und dann geht man wieder zurück zum Hauptprogramm.
Wobei Interrupt gab es ja eigentlich nur einen auf dem C64, auf dem 6502, wobei genau genommen gab es noch zwei, den NMI, den nicht maskierbaren, also den, den man nicht verhindern konnte.
Was nicht stimmt?
Man kann ihn maskieren. Also von der Hardware her, von der Perdefinition, kann man ihn nicht maskieren, aber es gibt einen Trick, dass man ihn maskieren kann. Und viele Spiele machen das, weil sie sonst teilweise aus dem Tritt kommen. Das ist total lustig, der NMI wurde, also gut, erst mal, Interrupt.
Was ist das?
Interrupt. Man, die CPU hat so einen Pin, Interrupt. Wenn da irgendjemand so eine 1 hinschickt oder eine 0, je nachdem wie da die Logik ist, dann hält die CPU das aktuelle Programm an und lässt so ein kleines Skript laufen, das den aktuellen Status von der CPU auf einen Stack pusht, mal so wegschreibt und dann bestimmt das Programm ausführt, dass man ihm irgendwo übergibt, dass der CPU mal gesagt hat, wo das so steht. Und dann läuft dieses Programm, man hat wieder volle Kontrolle, kann irgendwelche Sachen machen und dann macht man Return from Interrupt. Dann sucht sich der wieder den alten Zustand, den er mal weggespeichert hat und macht an der Stelle weiter. Das heißt, an C64, wenn ich den einfach mal so einschalte, ganz normal, da läuft schon ein Interrupt, nämlich ein Timer Interrupt, nämlich in einen von diesen IOU-Controllern, ist ein Timer Interrupt so eingestellt, dass er 60 Mal pro Sekunde mal diesen Interrupt auslöst. Und in diesem Interrupt-Handler werden jetzt mehrere Sachen gemacht. Das eine ist, dass die Tastatur abgefragt wird und dann in Tastaturpuffer reingeschrieben wird, weil die Tastatur ist ja auch, das sind ja nur irgendwie Leitungen, die da so auf 1 oder 0 gehen. Irgendjemand muss da regelmäßig mal schauen, was hier eigentlich passiert. Und der muss auch die Uhrzeit, es wird so eine Uhrzeit intern simuliert. Da ist so eine Uhr eingebaut, dass die immer hochgeschaltet wird, immer so in 60-Sekunden Abschnitten. Und was wird noch gemacht? Der Cursor wird geblinkt. Das heißt, der Cursor wird immer wieder das Zeichen eingeschaltet, ausgeschaltet, immer so in einem gewissen Takt. Also dafür wird es schon mal gemacht, Timer Interrupt. Das ist schon mal standardmäßig konfiguriert. Aber mehrere Chips am C64 sind eben an diesen Pin angeschlossen. Und da ist eben auch der Videocontroller angeschlossen. Und der kann sagen, ich will dich jetzt mal kurz anhalten, weil du hast mich danach gefragt, dass ich dich anhalte.
Aber die CPU weiß gar nicht, wer ihn jetzt sozusagen ausgelöst hat.
Erstmal nicht. Der muss dann die alle abklappern und fragen, was du's, und die sagen es einem dann. Deswegen gibt es auch mehrere Möglichkeiten. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt so ein Spiel programmiere, dann schalte ich normalerweise den Timer interrupt ab. Den will ich gar nicht mehr. Weil wieso will ich noch 16-mal die Sekunde unterbrochen werden?
Bringt dich kein Cursor?
Ich habe keinen Cursor. Die Uhrzeit interessiert mich. Die Tastatur frage ich irgendwie anders ab. Oder ich synchronisiere das Ganze eh besser zum Rasterstrahl, statt zu irgendeinem künstlichen Signal.
Weil der ist nur wirklich sehr verlässlich. Und das ist vor allem auch die einzige Größe, die einen wirklich interessiert beim Game.
Genau. Weil wenn ich so ein Spiel schreibe, dann ja Rasterzeit. Da geht es immer darum, wann kann ich was machen. Also wenn ich gerade im V-Blank bin, dann mache ich alles, was mit Grafik zu tun hat. Und wenn die Grafik gerade aufgebaut wird, dann kann ich Spiele-Logik machen.
V-Blank ist was?
Die vertikale Austastlücke. Also wenn ich im unteren, oberen Rahmen bin.
Also wenn er sozusagen wieder nach oben marschiert.
Wenn er zurückläuft, wenn er gerade mal nichts malt. Oder nichts sichtbares malt.
Der Wagenrücklauf. Der visuelle Wagenrücklauf.
Carried return, genau. Und deswegen ist immer jedes Programm oder jedes Spiel immer so synchronisiert. Das ist eigentlich so dieser Takt, um den es immer geht. Das ist eigentlich bei allen Computern so aus dieser Ära. Oder nach diesem Prinzip sind auch Gameboy und so weiter. Beim Gameboy glaube ich, kann ich noch nicht mal wirklich auf den Bildschirm überhaupt zugreifen. Da muss ich komplett, darf ich nichts machen. Ich kann immer nur, wenn gerade nichts gemalt wird, kann ich überhaupt mit Bildschirmspeicher was machen. Ja, Interrupts. Wir waren bei Interrupts. Also der VEC kann den unterbrechen. Die CA kann dann so einen Timer hinschicken. Und es gibt noch ein zweites Pin. Das sind die nicht maskierbaren Interrupts. Quasi eine zweite Quelle. Da wird dann auch ein anderes Programm ausgeführt. Passiert aber eigentlich genau dasselbe. Und der zweite IOU-Controller ist da angeschlossen. Im Endeffekt, da sind so ein Haufen Features, die eigentlich gar nicht benutzt werden. Zum Beispiel, dass dieser zweite Interface-Controller am NMI angeschlossen ist, benutzt das das Hauptbetriebssystem nicht. Aber da hatten sie halt, wir haben hier noch einen PIN, da kann man ein NMI anschließen. Ja, der kann auch ein Interrupt-Signal liefern. Okay, schließt man halt da an. Das kann man halt dann auch irgendwo mal verwenden. Aber das Interessante am NMI ist jetzt nicht nur an diesem Controller-Shift angeschlossen, sondern eben auch an einer Taste auf der Tastatur. Da frage ich dich jetzt mal, wie viele Tasten hatten C64? Auf der Tastatur.
Pfff, da fragst du mich was. Soll ich jetzt für dich nachrechnen?
Ihr eine Schätzung. Oder nein, ich sag's dir und du sagst mir warum. Gut, 66.
Okay, 66. Warum?
Das sind 64 plus zwei. Nämlich zwei Sondertasten, die irgendwie anders gehändelt werden. Und dann 64, weil das halt wunderbar eine 8x8-Matrix ist.
Ah, okay, alles klar. Und die beiden sind dann Runstop und Restore?
Nein, Runstop ist normal. Shift-Log. Shift-Log ist keine eigene Taste, das ist das selbe wie Shift. Das ist an dieselbe Leitung angeschlossen. Und Restore, genau. Restore wird nicht als Taste reingeliefert, sondern ist direkt an das NMI-Signal dran. Ein NMI kann man halt benutzen als so einen halben Reset. Deswegen, wenn man Restore macht, dann wird immer diese Routine aufgerufen, außer man hat sie explizit abgeschaltet. Und die Routine, die halt standardmäßig konfiguriert ist, die schaut, ob die Run-Stop-Taste auch noch gedrückt ist. Und dann hat man so einen kleinen Soft-Reset. Da werden die Bildschirmfarben wieder richtig gestellt, das Programm abgebrochen.
Das heißt, wenn man draufhaut, wird der NMI immer ausgelöst. Aber nur, wenn man Run-Stop gehalten hat, dann wurde auch was getan.
Und das Problem für Spiele war dann eben, dass man konnte den nicht maskieren. Das heißt, wenn jemand auf Restore gedrückt hat, während ein Spiel gerade so ganz tricky Effekte gemacht hat und halt den Videochip live neu programmiert hat, hat der das Timing durcheinander gebracht. Wenn man da ständig drauf gehämmert hat, dann hätte der Bildjam geflackert. Und das ist unschön. Oder teilweise hätte er wirklich vielleicht die Logik auch durcheinander gebracht. Deswegen gab es auch einen Trick, um den wirklich zu maskieren. Wie denn? Man muss eben diesen Timer in dem zweiten CIA, muss man auf in jedem Zyklus Feuer anschalten. Der zählt dir immer eine Zahl runter. Und immer, wenn er bei Null angekommen ist, lädt er wieder die Originalzahl und löst einen NMI in dem Fall aus. Das heißt, man setzt ihn auf 1 und sagt Feuer jedes Mal, wenn er unterläuft. Das heißt, er feuert in jedem einzelnen Zyklus. Das heißt, der NMI wird die ganze Zeit ausgelöst. Aber der NMI zählt nur dann, wenn er immer einen Übergang von 0 auf 1 hat.
Verstehe, das heißt, die CPU hat keine Änderungen gesehen, weil er immer an war.
Das heißt, für die CPU wird es so aussehen, als würde man einmal die Restore-Taste schon drücken, aber wird dann drauf bleiben. Wenn man sie hält, dann wird ja kein Neuer ausgelöst. Vor ein paar Jahren habe ich irgendwo im Internet mal gesehen, so ein Hacker-Test. Bist du wirklich ein Hacker? Und eine von den Fragen war, have you ever masked an NMI? Und so, yes, da konnte ich ankreuzeln, dann habe ich ein paar Punkte dazu gekriegt.
Ich glaube, ich habe ja auch mal gesehen, ein Test, da hatte ich glaube ich nicht so viele Punkte. Ich habe noch nie in einem NMI maskiert, aber ich habe zumindest diesen WIC ausgetrickst.
So, jetzt kommt deine Geschichte. Jetzt haben wir die Grundlagen dazu, oder?
Ja, weiß nicht. Also ich meine, damit hat man halt irgendwie rumgespielt. Ich meine, wie zieht man das jetzt auf? Weiß nicht, ist das überhaupt so wichtig? Tatsache ist, man konnte also Programme schreiben, die jetzt voll synchronisiert waren, auf die Bildschirmausgabe. Und da waren halt alle möglichen Tricks möglich dadurch. Man konnte halt vor allem alles, was so horizontal war. Also viele Spieler hatten immer so eine Horizontal-Optik. Und das lag einfach daran, weil man eben auf dieser Basis mit diesem Interrupt einfach gut arbeiten konnte. So ein vertikales Screensplitting zum Beispiel wäre jetzt überhaupt nicht in demselben Maße möglich gewesen. Sondern es war halt immer irgendwie alles horizontal. Und hat von daher auch so eine gewisse Optik und so ein gewisses Erscheinungsbild dieser Spiele immer wieder gemacht. Ich hatte halt damals da auch irgendwie drauf rumgehackt. Und wir haben halt irgendwann mal in so einem Team rumprogrammiert. Und auf einmal war halt der Rahmen weg. Das war halt irgendwie so ein ganz komischer Effekt. Also genau genommen war das so ein, ich weiß nicht mehr, was wir da überhaupt gemacht haben. Aber wir haben halt irgendwie mit Sprites rumprogrammiert. Und da muss man ja auch eben auf diesem Weg bestimmte Rasterwerte ein- und ausschalten. Also wie wir das hier so beschrieben haben, in diesem D000-Bereich gab es halt bestimmte Register. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie man diese Sprites irgendwie überhaupt einschaltet und so.
In D015, da hast du acht Bit drin. Also du hast acht Sprite. Und deswegen kannst du da in D015 kannst du die Sprites eins in den anderen ausschalten.
Genau, schalte man an und irgendwo anders im Speicher stehen dann irgendwelche Bitmaps, wie die aussehen.
Genau, interessanterweise nicht in den Registern, sondern das steht dann das Liste aus dem Speicher raus. Nämlich am Ende vom Bildschirmspeicher. Weil der Bildschirmspeicher ist ja nur 1000 Zeichen groß, 40x25. Und da hast du ja noch mal 24 Bytes dahinter, um das Kilobyte vollzukriegen. Und die letzten acht Bytes davon, da steht drin, wie die Sprites aussehen. Das sind nämlich dann Pointer im Speicher. Die werden halt mal 64 multipliziert. Und das ist dann die Adresse, wo dann die Sprites abgelegt sind.
Wie groß waren diese Sprites noch mal?
24x21. Das erkennt man nicht, 64 Bytes, 69 Bytes.
Gut, also irgendeine krumme Zahl auf jeden Fall.
Besonders groß sind sie nicht. Viele Spiele haben dann eben ein paar Sprites zusammengebaut. Also so ein 2x2-Sprites zusammen und die dann gleichzeitig bewegt. Dann hattest du ein ganz großes Endmonster.
Naja, auf jeden Fall saßen wir irgendwie zusammen. Ich und ein Freund von mir und ein Dritter, der auch noch mit hackte, der hatte ihm halt irgendwelchen Code mitgegeben auf irgendeinem Datenspeicher. Ich kann mich nicht mehr genau erinnern, was das war. Ob das jetzt schon Disketten waren? Ich glaube ja. Hatte halt irgendwie eine Diskette mit und meinte, ja hier, das hätte er irgendwie programmiert, aber das funktioniert irgendwie nicht. Da ist irgendwas komisch. So, ohne das jetzt näher zu spezifizieren und dann haben wir das halt irgendwie versucht, zum Laufen zu kriegen. Und auf einmal war halt dieser Rahmen weg. Der war einfach weg. So, also der Rahmen, dieser Rahmen war ja sozusagen auch so dieses, der war einfach immer da.
Ja, also da muss man vielleicht dazu sagen, wenn du außerhalb vom Rahmen, ich meine Zeichen oder so, kannst du keine Zeichen darstellen, kannst du den Bildschirmspeicher gar nicht dafür. Aber wenn du jetzt einen Sprite so weit an den Rahmen hintust, dass es halt halb aus dem Rahmen raus schaut, dann wird er halt vom Rahmen überdeckt.
Genau.
Der Rahmen war immer über allem, der hat alles immer weg überdeckt, also die Sprites halt, dass die Sprites halt aus dem Bildschirm quasi rausfliegen konnten und nicht einfach so plopp an einer Stelle weg waren.
Aber wir hatten irgendwie, glaube ich, es war halt irgendwie nur, es war nur so ein Code-Fragment, es war nur so irgendein Test, ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, was es war. Also es sollte noch gar nicht irgendwas Tolles tun und es tat auch nicht, es tat dann aber irgendwas Tolles und auf einmal war dieser Rahmen weg. Und wir saßen halt so ein bisschen so wie die Blöden da vor dem Rechner und dachten uns, was ist denn hier los? Und dann haben wir halt, glaube ich, die ganze Nacht damit verbracht, dieses Stück Code zu analysieren, was es denn nun eigentlich tatsächlich tat. Weil es tat ja definitiv nicht das, was es eigentlich tun sollte, sondern irgendetwas anderes, dessen Effekt uns eigentlich bisher für vollkommen unmöglich erschien. Na ja, und irgendwann kam er dann halt drauf, dass halt irgendwas falsch berechnet wurde und irgendwo wurde inkrementiert oder dekrementiert, wo es nicht hätte sein sollen und am Ende schrieb er halt bestimmte Daten zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt in ein bestimmtes Register.
Zeitpunkt ist immer der große Punkt, das ist meine Frage.
Genau, und irgendwie hatte das halt auch was mit diesem Interrupt, mit diesem WIC zu tun. Und dann haben wir es halt irgendwie geschafft, diesem Prozessor, und das deckt sich schön mit deiner Beschreibung so, er hatte ja immer nur so ein State und man konnte ihm sozusagen jederzeit immer wieder was ran, was reinschreiben und dann hatte er irgendwie kein Geschichtsgedächtnis, war alles vergessen. Und wir haben ihm sozusagen einfach zum richtigen Zeitpunkt glaubhaft gemacht, dass dieser Rahmen Bereich, was war denn das überhaupt, ach jetzt weiß ich es wieder, das ist diese Verschiebung nach oben und nach unten, oder?
Nein, es ist die 24 oder 25 Zeilen.
Ach ja, richtig, genau, was de facto so eine, genau, man konnte...
Passt auf das Scrolling benutzt, ja.
Genau, er hatte diesen Modus, dass er entweder 24 oder 25 Zeilen, ich weiß gar nicht warum, hat er diesen Modus überhaupt?
Ja, weil du hast halt dieses vertikale Scrolling, du kannst ja jetzt sagen, also vertikales Scrolling-Register kann von 0 bis 7, kannst du da reinschreiben, wenn du da 0 reinschreibst, dann hast du einen ganz normalen Bildschirm. Wenn du 1 reinschreibst, dann heißt das, dass der Bildschirm von 1 Pixel nach oben gesetzt ist. Das heißt, oben fehlt ein Pixel und unten ist ein extra Pixel, aber wo kommen denn die Daten für das extra Pixel her, du hast den Bildschirmspeicher gar nicht. Deswegen, wenn du ihn jetzt, sagen wir mal, um 7 wirklich nach oben schiebst, dann hast du unten wirklich 7 Pixel, wo nichts steht oder wo Müll steht, da macht er noch irgendwie so Müll-Fetches aus irgendeinem Speicherbereich. Und deswegen, immer wenn du vertical scrollen willst, dann musst du eigentlich auf 24 stellen, weil du halt immer eine halbe oben und eine halbe unten hast. Und sonst bräuchtest du halt wirklich 26. Und darum macht das halt um 8 Pixel kleiner. Oben um 4, unten um 4.
Genau, jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder. Und das war nämlich dann genau die Magie dieses Codes. Der hat nämlich diesem Chip zum richtigen Zeitpunkt irgendwie gesagt, dass er jetzt mal im 24, mal im 25-Modus war. Und in Abhängigkeit davon hat er halt irgendwie zum richtigen oder zu seiner Meinung nach richtigen Zeitpunkt angefangen und aufgehört diesen Rahmen zu zeichnen. Also unten hat er angefangen und oben hat er dann aufgehört. Und wenn man, ich glaube, unten ihm dann sozusagen, kurz bevor er dann anfangen würde mit dem Rahmen von 24 auf 25 schaltet oder von 25 auf 24, dann denkt er, ach, war ja schon. Genau.
Ich habe ihn ja schon angeschaltet.
Und dann fängt er gar nicht erst an und dann war der Rahmen auf einmal weg.
Und dann konntest du da unten Sprites reinlegen. Genau.
Und das war so unsere kleine Entdeckung. Und ich frage mich heute, bis bei heutigen Tage immer noch, ob wir eigentlich die ersten waren, weil später war das ja dann sozusagen so ein Standard-Feature bei allen Games.
Wie oft wurde die Avocado-Konstante entdeckt, ja? Wir müssen es zweimal.
Avocado-Konstante?
Chemie. Viele Entdeckungen kamen ja mehrfach. Ich glaube, damals war man ja nicht sonderlich connectet. Mit Internet hättest du einen entdeckt und dann hättest du alle gesehen. Damals saßen immer so drei Freaks irgendwo und dann haben sie es vielleicht an 64 mal ziehen oder an Input 64 geschickt. Dann wussten alle in dem Sprachbereich.
Genau.
Und dann haben es die Engländer und die Amerikaner und so und die Australier noch mal einzeln erfunden.
Das konnte eigentlich in jeder Stadt immer wieder alles neu entdeckt werden. Ich frage mich, ob wir da irgendwie vorne waren.
Da hat vor kurzem mal jemand gesagt, wo wir jetzt den 6502 versuchen, auch noch besser zu verstehen. Illegale Opcodes ist ja auch noch so eine Sache. Also Befehle, die eigentlich gar nicht spezifiziert sind. Opcodes, die es eigentlich gar nicht gibt, die in der Referenz fehlen. Was passiert, wenn man die jetzt ausführt? Und das hat die Leute schon immer fasziniert. Was ist da, wo nichts ist? Und die machen Sachen. Und viele davon versteht man bis heute nicht, was genau da passiert. Eben durch dieses Visual 65A2, wo man jetzt das komplette Modell hat, kann man das so ein bisschen simulieren oder herausfinden, was da wirklich passiert. Aber wir haben in der Praxis gesehen, dass es auf manchen Maschinen verhalten sich manche echt zufällig. Also echt zufällig. Und da haben wir jetzt auch Statistiken gemacht und so weiter. Da meinte auch mal jemand, das ist jetzt auch schon experimentelle Kernphysik, was wir hier machen. Also das sind ja winzigst kleine Teilchen oder winzigst kleine Zustände, die man versucht irgendwo zu messen, um zu schauen, was eigentlich wirklich in der CPU vorgeht.
Ja, Mensch, der C64. Was ja auch noch so meins, einer meiner Steckenpferde, als ich mich mit dieser Maschine auseinandergesetzt habe, war ja die Tatsache, dass das Kettenlaufwerk ja auch noch mal ein vollständiger Computer war und auch noch mal seinen eigenen 6502 Prozessor hatte.
Der hat sogar den echten, also nicht modifiziert, weil der nicht so viel Speicher hatte. Genau, da waren nur 4K an RAM drin. Waren es vier? Nee, 2K.
So wenig? Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Zwei Kilobyte von 0 bis 1000. Oder sind es 2K? Nein, es sind 4K. 0 bis 1000 sind 4K. Und dann einen Haufen ROM, das geht von 10.000 los. Das sind glaube ich 16K ROM. Brauchst du auch, weil das nicht nur das Dateisystem, sondern auch das komplette physische Format, nämlich so wie wird der jetzt in Sektor kodiert? Hat der ein Header und so weiter? Das wurde alles in Software gemacht von dieser CPU, die ja mit auch ein Megahertz getaktet wurde und somit schnell genug lief, in Echtzeit quasi die Bites da auf dieses Magnetfeld zu schaufeln.
War furchtbar langsam. Ich frage mich ja, ob die jungen Hörer, falls die überhaupt jetzt noch diesen Podcast hören, ob die uns eigentlich schon für komplett bekloppt sind. Also ich meine, bei dem Kettenlaufwerk wird mir das immer wieder klar. Ich meine, dieses Teil hatte was, 170 Kilobyte oder so?
Pro Seite. Du konntest ja andrehen.
So was nimmt man heutzutage überhaupt nicht mehr ernst. Aber auch da war es wieder so, man konnte das einfach auf eine Art und Weise, genau genommen geht das heutzutage natürlich auch. Wir wissen alle, wo die finnigen Hacker irgendwie ihren Code installiert bekommen und Firmware-Gepatches bekommen und so weiter. Hier so Tastatur-Firmware-Hacking und so weiter hatten wir ja auch gerade beim Kongress. Das ist ja eigentlich genau die gleiche Geschichte.
Heutzutage, ich meine, so eine Firmware von einer aktuellen Seagate-Festplatte macht ja auch nichts anderes. Da ist eine schnelle CPU drin, was weiß ich, was die da heute drin haben, die halt einfach so schnell läuft, dass sie da in irgendeinen I.O.-Port schnell genug das an den Schreiblesekopf reinpuschen kann.
Aber ich meine, damals war das auf jeden Fall was sehr Außergewöhnliches, dass man eben so einem Diskettenlaufwerk noch so ein kompletter Computer-CPU spendierte. Oder? Die anderen Diskettenlaufwerke waren auch eigentlich relativ tumme Teile, die so von außen gesteuert wurden. Und dass man eben für die Datenübertragung da so ein komplexes Protokoll dann auch sprach, so mit richtig CPU-Software auf beiden Seiten, das war außergewöhnlich. Ich frage mich nur, warum haben sie das eigentlich getan?
Ich glaube, die CPU, ich meine, sie haben ja die 6502 CPUs sehr billig gekriegt. Haben sie ja selber hergestellt. Und es war an sich eine sehr billige CPU. Vielleicht war das Design sogar billiger, als wenn man jetzt so einen fertigen Controller gekauft hätte, der das halt in Hardware deutlich limitierte. Aber halt direkt in so einem integrierten Chip gemacht hätte. Auf der anderen Seite, wie viel hast du gezahlt für dein Laufwerk? Ich glaube, da hat es die Platine auch keinen großen Unterschied mehr gemacht.
Das hat auch richtig viel Geld. Ja, weiß ich nicht, welchen Anteil da was hatte. Aber ich kann mich erinnern, dass die auch mehrere hundert Mark gekostet hat damals. Also es war...
Nur? Ah, dann hast du sie sehr spät gekriegt, oder? Ich glaube, die war anfangs über 1000.
Jaja. Also es war fast dasselbe wie der C64 eigentlich.
Von der Compostics... Also er ist sogar ein bisschen schneller getaktet.
Nee, ich meine auch vom Geld her jetzt.
Hat natürlich auch so einen geschichtlichen Grund. Denn die ersten Floppy-Laufwerke, die Commodore hergestellt hat, waren eben auch schon in dem Design. Und die waren halt eigentlich für deutlich größere, teurere Computer gedacht. Und das war dann einfach ein stripped-down Design. Für halt mehr den kleinen Bereich. Und da ist man bei dem Design geblieben. Es ist eh interessant, die... Wo ist das so, dass die ursprünglichen vom Design her, die hatten ja zwei CPUs, 26502, die halt immer so interlieft, immer so der einen Takt, der anderen Takt liefen, mit Speicher, der 2 Mhz war.
Wie war es von dem von denen, das Kettenlaufwerk? Die hatten da zwei CPUs drin?
Die alten, die 4040 oder die 8080, die für ein PET.
Ach so, die kannte ich nicht mehr.
Und der eine hat halt das Dateisystem gemacht und mit dem Computer gesprochen. Und der andere hat sich darum gekümmert, dass eben die Bits aufs Laufwerk geschrieben wurden. Wo die Bits vom Laufwerk gelesen und dekodiert wurden. Und in der 1541, also dieser Standard-Floppy vom C64, da hat man gespart und hat gesagt, naja, alles was zwei CPUs können, können doch einfach auch eine CPU in halber Geschwindigkeit. Und man schaltet einfach so und so oft pro Sekunde um zwischen den zwei Identitäten, zwischen zwei Persönlichkeiten. Das heißt, da schreibt mal so die eine CPU irgendwo in die Zero-Page ein Befehl rein. So, lesen wir doch den Sektor. Und die andere CPU liest das aus und macht das. Aber es ist nicht wirklich eine CPU, sondern dann wartet halt der, bis mal so ein Interrupt passiert und der die Persönlichkeit wechselt. Und dann, ach so, das meintest du, ja, das mache ich dir doch gerne.
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall alles schon ganz spannend. Man konnte ja dann auch über diese Schnittstelle Programme rüberladen und dann dort auch ausführen.
Nicht nur konnte, man musste fast. So schnecken langsam, wie das Ding war.
Ach so, ja, um dann sozusagen die Kommunikation zu beschleunigen. Ich hatte dann nur mal so ein Monitor geschrieben, so ein Programm, mit dem man sich sozusagen den Speicher auf dem Diskettendorfer anschauen konnte, aber halt mit dem selben User-Interface, wie man das so vom BASIC-Scrolling gewohnt war. Also einfach so mit Cursor hoch und runter durch den Speicher durchmarschieren und der hat sich das dann sozusagen in Realtime immer von der Floppy geholt.
War auch nicht besonders schnell, oder? Weil das Kommunikationsprotokoll war wirklich UHS.
Na im Vergleich zu der Datenmasse, die ich auf dem Bildschirm anzeigen musste.
Gut, Bildschirmdruck war auch nicht besonders schnell.
Ja, nee, also das war eigentlich relativ flüssig. Also der kriegt das dann immer schon so.
Du hast immer gleich so 40 Beiden auf einmal gelesen, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr, das ist alles ewig her. We're talking 80s here.
Ich meine, ich habe sowas erst letzte Woche gemacht. Ganz konkret bin ich da an irgendwelchen Sachen dran.
Ich bin ja mal Programmierer des Monats geworden beim heißen Verlag. Ja, also mit dem Teil, mit diesem Input 64, in diesem Disketten-Magazin.
Mit?
Mit dem Diskmon 1541.
Also was nur den Speicher von der Floppy angeschaut, oder eben die Sektoren von Medien?
Nee, es ging um... ob ich auch das Ketten... nee, ich glaube, es ging nur um den... weiß ich es gar nicht mehr.
Muss man nachgucken. Also blockweise anzuschauen ist natürlich auch spannend, dann kann man sich das Dateisystem anschauen und das halt...
ich glaube, es ging nur um den... ging es nur um den Spass. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Wenn man sich das heute so überlegt, es gibt ja so mit diesen neuen App-Gedanken auf iPhones und so gibt es ja wirklich für jeden Scheiß was, aber wenn man sich überlegt, wofür damals Programme geschrieben wurden und was dann Programm des Monats wurde, sind ja irgendwelche, das sind ja noch nicht mehr Hacker-Tools, das ist eigentlich alles überflüssig, das sind alles so, ich will meinen Computer ein bisschen besser verstehen, da gibt es noch ein Programm dafür oder? Der Computer kann eigentlich nichts, der ist total kaputt und ich mache hier mal ein Patch, ah, Programm des Monats.
August 1985. Du kannst ja mal zum Laufen gehen, was für eine Infrastruktur.
Schön, dass es Emulatoren gibt.
Ja, was haben wir denn jetzt noch? Irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen? Ich meine, man kann sich jetzt dumm und duttelig über diese Maschine reden, aber hast du das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt einen ganz wichtigen Aspekt noch rausgelassen haben, der dich so bei der täglichen Auseinandersetzung mit dieser Maschine aufs Regelmäßige immer wieder fasziniert?
Ja, gehen wir es nochmal durch. Also 6502 haben wir gut abgehakt.
Ja.
Der Videocontroller, ja. Ich programmiere ihn ständig neu, während er gerade das Bild malt. Ja, das ist eigentlich so der Hauptpunkt, was man dann so macht. SitChip haben wir jetzt fast gar nichts dazu gesagt, aber da kenne ich mich auch wirklich gar nicht aus, weil ich auch gar kein Musiker bin, leider. Da könnte man halt jetzt so Specs runterzählen und wie das so ein bisschen intern gelöst wird, aber...
Ja, ich habe ihn mal so ein bisschen programmiert. Ich habe mich seinerzeit auch ein bisschen mit beschäftigt mit den ganzen ADSR-Höhlkurven und so. Aber es ist halt so, wie man das eigentlich erwarten würde, wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Synthesizer auskennt. Also man kann halt alle diese Höhlkurve setzen. Also wie so wirklich jetzt so der Lautstärkenverlauf eines Tons ist. Und dann sagt man halt, ist das jetzt irgendwie Segezahn oder Sinus oder...
Nicht ganz Sinus, ist es Dreieck?
Ne, es gab diese vier.
Ja Sinus, nein, das war Dreieck. Also Dreieck schaut ja aus wie Sinus, also wenn du das Dreieck ein bisschen abstumpfst, wenn du die harten Ecken rausnimmst, das heißt, wenn du halt die hohen Frequenzen wegfilterst, kommst du an Sinus.
Also wie sauber das jetzt Sinus war, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, das ist ja gerade wieder der Punkt, wie wurde das halt auch implementiert. Denn in Sinus, da hätten sie eine Sinus-Tabelle haben müssen. Und Dreieck ist viel einfacher. Du zählst da rauf, du zählst da runter. Deswegen haben sie Dreieck gemacht und einfach danach in hardware einen Filter geschaltet, der die hohen Frequenzen rausnimmt. Dann bist du sehr nah dran am Sinus. Viel billiger.
So habe ich mir das gar nicht vergegenwärtigt. Auf jeden Fall konnte man eben so verschiedene Klangcharakteristika da lesen. Und dann war es eine Zeit lang so in meinem Umfeld war das so der Sport. Das war eigentlich so unser primärer Hacksport für eine Weile, Computerspiele zu nehmen. Man sitzt da so als kleines Kind und man spielt zu seinen Games und man ist vollkommen erfasst von diesem Programm. Und zwar entweder wegen des Gameplays oder nur weil man so viel Zeit damit rumbringt und die ganze Zeit immer diese Musik judelt. Und dann will man dann irgendwann diese Musik einfach auch mal hören, ohne aber jetzt die ganze Zeit diese Programme laden zu müssen. Weil das ja natürlich auch mal alles lange dauert und dann muss man irgendwie hier drücken und da drücken und schon weiter.
Manche Leute haben es auf Kassette aufgenommen.
Und was wir gemacht haben ist, wir sind dann halt einfach in diesen Code reingegangen von den Programmen und haben halt die Routinen heraus sizziert, die eben während des Gameplay den Sound abspielen. Also haben sozusagen alles andere herausgenommen und nur diesen Code extrahiert und das dann wiederum in so ein Standalone-Programm verfrachtet, das eben ohne dieses Spiel auch überlebte. Mucke rausziehen. Und ja, dann war das so, das war dann noch mal so die Hacktätigkeit, so ha, das hab ich jetzt mal wieder. Und das ist natürlich ein super Training auch, weil man hat irgendwie ein klar definiertes Ziel. Man weiß ganz genau, wann man fertig ist. Jedes Programm ist anders.
So hat man damals gelernt, also ein bisschen Zeitschriften, so ein bisschen Kurse, ja, wenn mal so was ein bisschen advanced war, aber im Grunde, du schaust dir was an und disassemblierst es. Das ist eigentlich fast Open Source. Heutzutage wird man sich Open Source durchlesen, um mal was zu verstehen, wie machen andere was. Damals, die Programme waren ja so klein. Das ist immer ein kleines Assembler. Man sucht nach so paar Stichwörter, wie wo schreibt er jetzt in CID rein oder in VEC und dann liest man sich den Code durch, man druckt sich vielleicht mal so fünf Seiten aus. Das habe ich immer sehr viel gemacht, mir das Programme komplett ausgedruckt, die mich interessiert haben und dann halt kommentiert. Und so hat man dann gelernt. Genau.
So wie eben auch mit dem von dir schon angedeuteten, aber vom Namen her nicht erwähnten, Buch, C64 intern von DataBacker, die es ja auch bis in die heutige Zeit geschafft haben zu überleben.
Oder?
DataBacker gibt es noch, oder? Bücher, oder nicht?
Ich weiß, dass die irgendwann mal so Billigsofte und sowas hergestellt haben.
Ja, ja, das auch. Damals schon.
Interessante Bücher.
Datamat.
Ach so, ja, stimmt.
Faktomat. Das waren immer so die Stern-Mat-Programme irgendwie. Aber DataBacker hatte damals schon einen sehr bedenklichen Ruf. Gibt es noch hier. Website- und SEO-Software.
Rot-Weißes Design, immer die Bücher. Teilweise die Bücher echt am C64 getippt, das haben wir noch gesehen. Die wurden mit einem Nadel-Drucker gedruckt und dann eben nachher vervielfältigt. Genau, da konnte man wirklich Informationen herziehen.
Aber dieses Buch war wirklich legendär, nicht? Das besteht ja zur Hälfte nur aus dem ausgedruckten Rom-Listing von diesem Ding. Da könnte man sich als kleiner Junge hinsetzen und las sich einfach seitenweise lang Assemblercode durch. Teilweise kommentiert, teilweise vollständig unkommentiert, so totale Beidwüste.
Ich frage mich, ob es weite Tage noch 12-Jährige gibt, die irgendwas Vergleichbares machen.
Doch, ich glaube, es machen immer noch welche.
Müssen wir mal schauen. Siehst du welche in der Vermannschaft?
Was? 12-Jährige?
Oder kennst du irgendwelche Lehrer oder sowas, die mal in der Schule nachfragen können? Die Hacker von heute. Also die wirklich Kinderhacker.
Ja, wenn ich mir immer so diesen ganzen Nachwuchs der letzten Jahre anschaue, die so im CCC aufschlagen, das ist schon so der Style.
Also dann so Linux-Befehls-Style, so von der Ecke?
Alle hängen jetzt nicht mehr am C64, aber im Prinzip das, was sie tun, ist nach wie vor dieselbe Intensität. Und ich denke, das geht ja auch gar nicht anders. Weil man merkt immer so bei den Kids, was weiß ich wann die dann immer angefangen haben, das wird ja irgendwie immer früher, aber es gibt dann halt so eine entscheidende Phase. Und ich würde sagen, bei denen Hackern, die dann wirklich am Ende auch wirklich so dieses vollständige Verständnis haben. Weißt du, kennst du dieses Gefühl, wenn du mit so Leuten redest, die so Techniker sind und die sich so mit Computern auseinandersetzen. Und egal was die machen, es kann sein, dass die super komplexe Programme schreiben, dass die irgendwas machen. Aber es gibt so welche, die haben diese Computer verstanden und es gibt welche, die haben sie nicht verstanden. Es gibt so Leute, die können das irgendwie alles so bedienen und sind dann irgendwie so zufrieden mit ihren Ergebnissen, aber die bleiben einfach immer an so einem bestimmten Punkt auch stehen. Vielleicht auch bewusst stehen. Und das ist ja auch jetzt nichts Schlimmes, wir das nicht abwerten, die haben nach wie vor ihre Ergebnisse und so. Aber dann gibt es dann immer wieder diese anderen, die einfach auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise so total erleuchtet sind, weil die einfach da das Licht gesehen haben, weil die einfach wissen, wie es für die Maschine funktioniert und ich bin da auch einmal so tief im Keller gewesen und hatte da so mein Aha-Moment. Und das ist natürlich ein goldenes Wissen. Also da kann ich auch jeden immer nur zu ermutigen, das dann auch anzustreben, weil wenn man dann einfach so dieses vollständige Verständnis von dieser Kernmaschine gehabt hat, dann kann man sich daraus alles andere irgendwie wieder herleiten. Das ist wirklich so ein goldener Moment, auf dem man dann alles wieder aufbauen kann. Ich kann euch alle nur ermutigen.
Ja, da einsteige ich heute, also wenn man wirklich jetzt direkt konkret in so eine C64 Richtung heutzutage einsteigen wollen würde, dann kann man das ja auch sehr schön mit den Emulatoren machen, die vor allem einem dann gleich mal ein bisschen Einblick geben, was die normale Maschine halt nur mit sehr viel Gebastel einem gegeben hätte. Nämlich da kann man einfach mal in den Monitor reingehen und sagen, ja zeig mir doch mal Speicher an. Also das Programm wirklich anhalten, wirklich perfekt anhalten, weil ja nur die Emulation genau in dem Zyklus dann aufhört.
Man sieht alles, alle Registerzustände, alle Speicherzustände.
Also alle Zustände, auch so interne Zustände, die man normalerweise gar nicht sehen kann.
Gibt es da sowas Schönes für eine C64? Vielleicht haben wir das mal erwähnt. Es gibt ja so ein paar Emulatoren. Ich habe neulich mal wieder geschaut, was es da eigentlich so gibt. Es gibt dieses Power 64, zumindest auf dem Mac.
Ja, ich will es jetzt nicht abwerten, aber so wie ich das jetzt verstehe...
Ich will es jetzt auch nicht aufwerten. Es war nur so, dass...
Also Power 64 ist Shareware auf dem Mac. Oder es gibt es nur für Mac und ist Shareware. Und der Punkt ist, dass es eben sehr optimiert für PowerPC geschrieben. Und es läuft halt momentan in der Rosetta-Emulation. Und seit fünf Jahren gab es kein Update. Also es ist sehr vollständig und sehr kompatibel. Also kompatibel genug für das Allermeister, was man machen will. Es ist ein sehr schöner Monitor dabei und so weiter. Aber ich glaube, ansonsten nach fünf Minuten, zehn Minuten oder so haut er einen raus, weil es eben Shareware ist. Aber es gibt noch zwei andere Projekte, die zumindest auf dem Mac laufen, wenn wir uns darauf jetzt mal konzentrieren wollen.
Ja, oder auch auf anderen Plattformen. Wir können vielleicht erstmal den Mac machen.
Grundsätzlich, es gibt mal...
Frodo gab es auch noch.
Frodo, der ist Cross-Plattform. Aber der ist eher auf Geschwindigkeit gemacht, nicht so sehr auf perfekt. Das ist also die Frage, wie perfekt willst du ihn emulieren? Weil man muss halt total weit gehen. Wenn jemand ein Programm auf die Floppy hochlädt und ausführt, dann heißt das, dass man nicht einfach die Floppy high level emulieren kann und sagen kann, ach ja, da will ich jetzt was lesen. Okay, dann lese ich halt was von Platte. Sondern ach, da läuft ja auch eine CPU. Die muss ich auch Zyklus für Zyklus einzeln in 650.02 durchsteppen. Ich meine, heutzutage macht es jeder Emulator. Aber bei manchen ist es auch optional. Und bei manchen ist die Emulation jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig. Also eigentlich der eine große Emulator ist eben der VICE, V-I-C-E. Der emuliert nicht nur C64, sondern auch C128 Plus 4. Eigentlich die komplette 8-Bit-Serie, auch den PET. Und der ist Open Source unter der GPL, gibt es für alle Betriebssysteme. Auf dem Mac ist der noch ein bisschen holprig. Da gibt es jemanden, der kümmert sich darum, dass es auf dem Mac gut aussieht. Aber nur der C64-Emulator, der ist vollständig und kann auch alles schön über UI erreichen. Die anderen, die haben noch keine komplette UI. Also weiss, wer jetzt da mein Emulator auf Choice ist. Auf Windows gibt es dann noch zwei andere, den CCS64 und den HOXS64. Die sind beide Closed Source. Der eine ist auch Shareware. Aber im Grunde mit Weiß ist man wirklich sehr gut bedient.
Der gibt einem dann wirklich einen Blick in alle Register etc.
Ja, der hat ein Monitor eingebaut. Da unterbreche ich dann und lasse mir das alles anzeigen. weißteam.org.
Ja, das Netzwerk zickt hier gerade ein bisschen rum. Deswegen kann ich jetzt gerade nicht so klug nachschlagen. Immer diese Internetverbindung in der Diaspora.
Sehr interessant ist es dann auch im Emulator. Man kann dann auch im Emulator mal nachschlagen, wie dann intern was gemacht wird, wenn man was nicht versteht. Oder vielleicht auch mal noch so ein Print-App reinsetzen und sich den Vice neu kompilieren. Das ist an Emulation halt immer das Schöne.
Ja, das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall so zum Forschen. Das ist irgendwie cool. Aber auf jeden Fall sollte man auch mal sich einfach einen C64 mal shoppen auf eBay und auf den Tisch stellen. Und da gibt es ja auch noch ein paar ganz coole Games, die man auch spielen kann.
Ja, bestimmt. Ja, also so muss man...
Ist alles nicht so exciting wie jetzt World of Warcraft und 3D mit irgendwie den latest and greatest Graphics?
Ich habe vor kurzem wieder Bubble Bobble ausgepackt und mal mit einem Freund gespielt. Das ist schon krass, macht Spaß, zu zweit vor allem.
Da gibt es ja jetzt noch diese Demoscene. Das muss man jetzt auf jeden Fall auch noch mal aufs Tablett holen. Weil da muss ich sagen, da ist mir schon so einiges aus dem Gesicht gefallen. Es gibt so Programme aus dieser Demoscene, die auf diesem C64 Dinge tun, wo ich mich wirklich frage, wie machen die denn das?
Ja, das freue ich mich meistens auch noch. Und dann muss man halt ein bisschen analysieren. Dann geht man mit dem Debagger ran, oder?
Was kannst du zu dieser Szene sagen?
Also Demoszene, da bin ja ich jetzt auch fast so ein, ja eigentlich eher ein Außenseiter noch, weil die Demoszene gab es ja schon lange vor mir und ich war auch nie so hundertprozentig drin. Ich habe ein bisschen mitgemischt, habe auch mal in DiscMag den Code dafür geschrieben, habe mal irgendwo ein Intro auch für was anderes geschrieben. Was ist das denn? Disc-Ketten-Magazin. Also aus der Demoszene auch die DiscMag's gab es ja da, weil so Szenenews und so, die halt immer kostenlos waren und konnte man verbreiten und so. Und da waren eben auch ein bisschen Demos dabei oder irgendwie sowas. Also die Demoszene entstammt ja eigentlich aus dieser Cracker-Szene. Das hat damals schon so funktioniert wie heute. Irgendjemand hat das Spiel entweder gekauft oder geklaut oder sowas. Dann hat das seinem Spätzle gegeben, der ging dann mit dem Disassembler ran und hat versucht, den Kopierschutz auszuhebeln. Weil, naja, hätte man die Disc-Kette halt einfach versucht, so Block für Block zu kopieren, hat die Kopie nicht funktioniert. Dann hat man herausgefunden, was genau ist da vorgegangen. Und wahrscheinlich meistens wurde halt Kot ins Floppy-Laufwerk hochgeladen, der dann noch irgendeinen Check gemacht hat, weil auf der Disc-Kette doch irgendwo noch ein Bit war, das eigentlich gar nicht so dahin gehört hätte. Und dann gab es halt jemanden, der das dann wieder verschickt hat an all seine Kontakte. Also das war damals die Cracker-Szene. Und das hat sich dann eingebürgert in der Cracker-Szene, dass man ja natürlich auch stolz auf das, was man gemacht hat. Ich meine, klar, man war anonym, man hatte halt die schönen Hacker-Handles und hat davor dann immer noch ein Intro gebaut. Nämlich so ein kleines Programm, das gesagt hat, hallo, wir sind die Cracker-Gruppe so und so, an dem und dem Tag haben wir diesen Hack released. Wenn sie dann noch gut waren, dann haben sie da auch noch einen Trainer reingebaut, dass man unendlich Leben hatte oder so, sodass die Sprite-Kollision abgeschaltet war, wenn man das haben wollte, war halt optional. Und diese Intros, die wurden mit der Zeit auch immer schöner, immer besser, weil die Leute halt so Sachen herausgefunden haben wie, wie schalte ich den Rahmen ab? Und haben halt dann her gezeigt, Leute, schaut, wir können den Rahmen abschalten, wir können nicht nur dieses Game hacken, den Kopierschutz hacken, sondern wir haben auch ein wirklich sehr schönes Intro am Anfang mit unserer eigenen Musik und so weiter. Das heißt, da ist halt ein Text durchgelaufen, ist irgendwie ein Logo so rumgehüpft, sind irgendwelche horizontalen Balken in allen Farben hin und her gehüpft. Und es wurde immer besser und irgendwann hat sich da so eine eigene Szene gebildet, die sich ein bisschen distanziert hat von diesem Cracken und gesagt hat, wir interessieren uns einfach nur, solche Demos zu bauen, nämlich im Endeffekt solche Intros, die dann auch aus mehreren Teilen bestanden und immer mal wieder so einen Effekt gezeigt haben. Somit, wir haben es jetzt, also Beispiel wieder, wir haben es jetzt geschafft, den Bildschirm unten aufzumachen, den Rahmen weg zu zeigen und dann setzt man da ein paar Sprites rein, lässt die flackern, lässt die hin und her hüpfen, schaut mal, was wir geschafft haben. Und dann die nächsten, die haben es geschafft, einen Bildschirm vertikal mit riesengroßen Grafiken hin und her zu scrollen, was normalerweise einfach gar nicht funktionieren würde. Das interessante ist, wenn man sich sowas anschaut, teilweise schaut es wirklich schön aus für jemanden, der auch gar nichts versteht davon und teilweise muss man den Kontext verstehen, dass sowas eigentlich auf der Hardware eigentlich gar nicht hätte möglich sein sollen. Und dann denkt man sich, wie können die das jetzt machen? Denn man kann halt keine 16 Farben Bitmaps eigentlich scrollen. Irgendjemand hat anscheinend einen Trick herausgefunden. Und später haben sich dann die Leute eben zu diesen Demo-Partys getroffen und haben ihre Demos da vorgestellt und die wurden dann bewertet, dann wurden Plätze vergeben. Wenn man sich das alles mal anschauen will, die CSDB, die Commodore SINA Database, die URL ist ein bisschen komplizierter, aber Google weiß die. Also einfach CSDB. Ich glaube CSDB C64 Org oder sowas. Die sammeln alle Demos und alle Szenen und machen da riesig Cross-Reference. Also da kannst du suchen, welche Gruppe hat wann mit wem, welches Demo gemacht. Und die Demos werden auch immer noch gemacht. Also diese Partys gibt es immer noch. Sind inzwischen ein bisschen kleiner, sind teilweise noch dieselben Leute, die sich da immer mal wieder treffen und dann ihre Demos herzeigen.
Das wird ja absurd, ich meine, da werden so irgendwelche Echtzeit-3D-Sachen laufen da. Das ist irre.
Ja, immer wieder. Das ist faszinierend, dass man auch heute noch immer wieder einen neuen Trick findet, wie man so eine HD-3D-Transformation doch in Echtzeit oder noch schneller, noch besser, noch optimierter hinkriegt, damit man noch eine höhere Frame-Rate hinkriegt. Das war damals eigentlich unvorstellbar. Da gab es vielleicht doch mal hin und wieder ein Rennspiel. Da gab es so Grand Prix Circuit und Test Drive. Die hatten ja nur eine Frame-Rate von vielleicht 10 Frames pro Sekunde. Das war wirklich nicht schön. Aber es hat sich angefühlt wie ein Rennspiel. Und das war halt so nicht echtes 3D, das war so ein Pseudo-3D. Somit, ja, die Autos male ich jetzt mal ein bisschen größer und kleiner. Und im Endeffekt, bei so einer Rennstrecke schaut die Strecke auch immer gleich aus. Da kann ich ein paar Bilder irgendwie immer hin und her zeigen. Aber was die Demos da heutzutage zeigen, wo die da irgendwelche komplexen 3D-Objekte mit vier Farben auf dem Bildschirm dann in, weiß ich nicht, 20 frames pro Sekunde da rumrotieren, das verstehe ich selber nicht. Vor allem das jetzt zu Reverse-Engineeren, das ist ein bisschen komplizierter, weil da musst du halt wirklich den Algorithmus dahinter verstehen. Das ist nicht so ein kleiner Trick, wie zu welchem Zeitpunkt schreibe ich was in welches Register.
Ja, das ist wirklich absurd.
Diese Demo-Szene, die hat ihr dann auch später auf Amiga und auf PC ist die so ein bisschen drüber. Auf PC glaube ich, sind es heutzutage immer so, ich versuche in möglichst kleinem Code mit möglichst wenig Dependencies.
64 Kilo Bytes ist dann so auch.
Versuche ich dann auf Windows irgendwie so ein Spiel oder irgendwas, was irgendwie ist immer 3D, immer was Tolles in 3D zu machen. Also da lebt es auch so ein bisschen noch. Amiga glaube ich und alle anderen Demosachen sind eher ausgestorben, aber C64 ist da immer noch dabei.
Weil es einfach so eine wunderbar definierte Plattform ist.
Ja, die hat sich auch nie geändert. Wobei, da könnte man noch dazu kommen, es gibt ja doch ein paar Revisionen von C64, die halt ganz kleine subtile Änderungen hatten. Also heutzutage, wenn man sich das so überlegt, wie extrem unterschiedlich eigentlich Rechner sind, aber doch kompatibel, weil halt niemand auf so einer unteren Ebene programmiert, da ist das eigentlich ein Witz, was damals die Unterschiede waren. Aber zum Beispiel haben sie da so eine Board-Revision eingeführt, 86 oder 87 kam das Board raus, das kleinere Board, wo sie ein bisschen was zusammengelegt haben. Und plötzlich war das Timing von dem Timer Interrupt. Der Timer Interrupt kam um einen Taktzyklus früher als vorher. Und ein paar Programme haben dann nicht mehr funktioniert. Oder auch dieser Soundchip, den sie dann neu gemacht haben.
Die mussten halt einfach total identisch sein.
Ja, aber abgesehen von diesen paar winzigen Kleinigkeiten, die man weiß, sind die Dinge wirklich identisch. Deswegen kann man sich exakt auf diese Hardware verlassen. Und man spielt es auf diese Hardware ab und dann verhält sich das halt wirklich identisch.
Und dann ist es natürlich jetzt für so Leute mit Sportsgeist, wie ich jetzt mal die Demoscene so sehe, natürlich eine wunderbare Plattform, weil sie einfach hochgradig vergleichbar ist.
Ja, was du vorher noch gesagt hast, weil du ja gesagt hast, SID-Dateien oder ja, vom SID Musik zu extrahieren, die man dann so stand-alone als Programme hatte zum Abspielen, das ist ja genau das, was das HVSC, die High Voltage SID Collection, so richtig mal en masse gemacht hat.
High Voltage?
Die kennst du gar nicht.
Nein.
Dann kennst du auch nicht den SID-Player.
Na, ich kenne so SID-Player, aber High Voltage.
Die HVSC ist, ich glaube, das waren mal so 50 Megabyte komprimiert, wahrscheinlich jetzt größer. Da sammeln die Leute genau das, was du da beschrieben hast. Man nimmt sich die Spiele vor oder die Demos oder wo auch immer man Musik hatte und zieht nur die Musik raus und schreibt es in ein eigenständiges Programm. Und das ist dann ein standardisiertes Dateiformat, dass man sich in so ein SID-Player reinziehen kann. Der emuliert dann nicht nur den Soundchip, sondern eben auch die 65002 CPU, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass man in den Soundchip ganz einfach irgendwie ein Programm rein tut oder in das Hodenblatt.
Nämlich von dem Code ab, der das dann so richtig reinschiebt.
Genau.
Das wird ja sozusagen gleich mit emuliert.
Genau. Das heißt, so eine SID-Datei ist immer ein Programm, ein echtes 65002 Programm, so ein Player, der halt dann seine Daten hat, die er dann in den SID in der richtigen Reihenfolge und im richtigen Timing reinschreibt. Und also dieser SID-Player für Mac, der ist wirklich sehr, sehr schön.
Ach so in iTunes-Optik.
Schaut aus wie iTunes, verhält sich aber nicht wie iTunes glücklicherweise.
Super. Oh Mann. Das ist echt keine tote Plattform. Das kann man wirklich nicht behaupten. Erstaunlich. Echt erstaunlich, was das so für lange Auswirkungen hat.
Ich glaube auch, dass momentan ist wieder so eine Phase, wo es wieder mehr wird. Ich glaube hauptsächlich die alten Leute von damals. Teilweise habe ich auch gesehen, dass wirklich junge Leute, jetzt wieder so 15-Jährige rekrutiert werden, die sowas spannend finden, die halt einfach nicht befriedigt werden können von einem iPad.
Ja, weil das Ding auch jetzt irgendwie so alt ist, dass es auch schon wieder so ein Beyond-Vintage-Charakter hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das ausdrücken soll. Es ist irgendwie schon wieder so eine Perle der Vergangenheit, die man dann auch irgendwie kennengelernt haben muss und die man nicht abtun kann, als auch, das ist doch altes Zeug, da kann ja mein PC viel mehr und so.
Ja, das ist vor allem so eine Kindheitserinnerungssache. Vor kurzem erst ist ein alter Schulfreund von mir, hat mir eine E-Mail geschrieben und halt gesagt, ja du, C64 und so, ich habe dir doch damals mein C64 gegeben oder meine Disketten habe ich dir gegeben, ob er die wieder haben kann. Weil die lagen noch im Keller meiner Eltern. Ja, weil er hat sich jetzt bei eBay wieder einen gekauft und ja, die gute alte Zeit damals und die Spiele haben so viel Spaß gemacht und das würde er jetzt nochmal machen. Gut, also manche sehen es halt von der Spiele-Seite her und manche eben von dem, das hat doch Spaß gemacht, das damals zu programmieren.
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen. Ich hatte auch neulich mal überlegt, wo ist eigentlich mein C64?
Welchen hattest du denn? Alter Broadkasten oder? Naja, ja ja, Broadkasten gewesen sein.
Ja ja, Broadkasten. Also das spätere Design, das sagte mir auch irgendwie nicht so richtig zu.
Genau deswegen sind sie davon hier wieder abgekommen, in Deutschland. Die Deutschen mochten das nicht.
Ach echt?
Deswegen, also es gab ja drei Gehäuse-Typen, nämlich den alten, den Broadkasten, den normalen, der hieß C64, dann den etwas flacheren in diesem neuen Design, so ähnlich war auch der Amiga und so, und dann hellere, helles Beige, das war dann schon moderner. Das war der C64, also in Deutschland hat man immer C64-2 genannt. Das war das 64er-Magazin, hatte ich mal so genannt. In Wirklichkeit war das der C64C, stand auch auf dem Typenschild so drauf. Aber das Hauptproblem mit dem war, dass der eben flacher war und deswegen diese ganzen Hardware-Basteleien und Erweiterungen, die die Leute da so reingeschraubt haben und reingelötet haben, teilweise nicht mehr reingepasst haben. Und also gerade in Deutschland war eben dieses Bastelertum sehr groß und deswegen sind sie, also sie sind zweigleisig gefahren. Sie haben für Deutschland auch das Original-Design wieder eingeführt, allerdings dann mit hellerem Gehäuse und der helleren Tastatur, sodass die Tastatur gleich war, weil früher war es ja eine braune Tastatur im Alpen. Und das war der C460G, G für Germany. Ach echt? Und der wurde gerade halt auch in unserem Bereich nur verkauft. Das ist eh so, wenn man sich anschaut, wann war der wirklich, wann war der hip? Der ist halt wirklich von Westen nach Osten gewandert in seiner Zeit. So 1983, 84 hat er sich hauptsächlich in den USA verkauft. In Deutschland war er noch gar nicht so. Da haben sich die Leute den wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht leisten können. Dann die Hochzeit in Deutschland war eigentlich eher so 86. Nach 86, 87 war der in den USA quasi schon tot. Ich glaube, 88 haben sie aufgehört, den USA überhaupt zu verkaufen. Aber in Deutschland lief er noch bis 94.
Echt krass.
Und die 80% von den C64 produziert wurden, wurden in Europa verkauft. Und das Allermeister davon auch in Deutschland. Also deswegen eigentlich auch wieder so eine Zwei-Generationen-Frage. Eigentlich drei Generationen. Die erste Generation Amerika, 84, zweite Generation, 86, Deutschland und dann so 89 oder was, 90. Dritte Generation, die späten C64 Leute in Deutschland.
Und dann war es dann irgendwann mal richtig tot. Und dann kam das irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren wieder auf mit so, was ich, da gab es so ein C64 in einem Joystick.
Ja, der DTV.
So hieß der.
Der C64 DTV Direct-to-TV, das ist die Jerry Aliceworth, die hat den komplett nachimplementiert, hat also in VHDL mit einem FPGA wirklich den neu designed. Hatte halt also die Specs oder wusste halt, wie der funktioniert in allen Details mit dem Emulator, oder halt in dem Emulator kann man nachschlagen, da kann man genau sehen. Es gibt auch einen Haufen Docs von Leuten, die das einfach aufgeschrieben haben, also die halt das alles durchgemessen haben, also da gibt es von Christian Bauer zum Beispiel sehr schöne VEC2-Manual, da steht halt exakt das Timing drin, das ist einmal an einer Stelle super zusammengefasst, was genau passiert, so in der Rasterseile, wann macht er jetzt, wann liest er eigentlich jetzt vom Speicher, wann genau muss ich was machen? Also so wie du und ich das noch gemacht haben, haben wir halt ausprobiert und so machen wir ein Cyklus früher, okay, schaut besser aus, ein Cyklus später, okay, so und so schaut es aus. Inzwischen ist das ja alles verstanden, Emulatoren machen es ja richtig und das haben wir halt so Ende der 90er oder so Mitte, Ende der 90er haben Haufen Leute eben das alles dokumentiert und alles zusammengeschrieben. Auch nochmal so eine Phase an der ganzen Sache. Auf jeden Fall anhand von diesen Dokumentationen und also es ist ja wirklich eine gut verstandene Plattform heutzutage, gab es eben da so eine Reimplementierung vom C64 und das ist ja heutzutage wirklich kein Problem. Wir haben vorher gesagt, du könntest 200.000 von der CPU in so einen aktuellen Intel-Chip reinkriegen. Und deswegen konnte man diesen Joystick, ich glaube der wurde für 30 Euro verkauft, das war so ein Competition Pro Joystick, also der Standard Joystick, der in Deutschland wirklich sehr erfolgreich war. Oder auch weltweit sehr erfolgreich war und der ging auch nie kaputt. Also mir persönlich hat er nie gefallen, aber...
Ich mochte den auch nicht. Ich mochte den Atari-Joystick, der ging zwar laufend kaputt, aber der war irgendwie cooler.
Ja, ich musste auch immer diese Federkontakte da drin wieder neu spannen, neuen Federn und so in den anderen Joysticks. Auf jeden Fall, ja, so ein kleiner Joystick, da geht ein, ich glaube, ein Composite-Kabel an der einen Seite raus und das war es dann auch. Batterien, batteriebetrieben war der. Und da haben sie halt in so einem Flash-ROM schon mal 10 Spiele reinprogrammiert gehabt. Und da ist auch wieder so eine kleine, das war jetzt vor 5 Jahren oder so was, so eine, 5, 6 Jahre, ja, da ist so eine kleine Szene da wieder aufgeblüht an der Stelle. Wo dann die Leute gesehen haben, okay, das ist jetzt irgendwie so was wie ein C64. Also es gab auch schon mal, es gab den Commodore One.
Wie kompatibel war denn der?
Nicht sonderlich. Also ja, momentan arbeiten auch wieder ein paar Leute von Vesalia, das ist so eine Firma, die macht immer noch C64-Krams. Keine Ahnung, wie die sich halten. Also auch so Adapter, dass du eine C64-Tastatur an einem PC anschließen kannst.
Das ist so richtig so ein Business.
Die machen also immer wieder so neue Sachen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viel Geld da rauskommt, aber die bauen momentan auch wieder eine C64 nach in einem FPGA, das ist dann das Chameleon. Und das Interessante daran ist, das ist eigentlich so ein Steckmodul, das man hinten reinsteckt in den Expansionsport, wo man mal eine Speicherweiterung oder sowas reinstecken würde oder so was wie eine Final Cardridge oder eine Action Replay für so eine ROM-Erweiterung oder für eine Betriebssystem-Erweiterung. Da steckst du das rein. Und im Grunde läuft da, also du nimmst einen normalen C64 her, aber im Grunde läuft da eine C64-Emulation oder halt eine Reimplementierung in einem FPGA gleichzeitig mit. Und der hat seinen eigenen Videochip, der dann ein VGA-Signal hinten rausbringt.
Also du nimmst einen C64 und steckst einen C64 in einem FPGA hinten an den Expansionsport ran. Und was macht, also warum?
Also das ist halt die Kiste, die kann alles. Wenn du keinen C64 anschließt und hast nur die Kiste allein, das ist auch ein C64. Da musst du nur einen Strom anschließen und eine Tastatur. Und dann auf der anderen Seite VGA. Und dann wäre das ein kompletter C64. Und nicht nur ein normales.
Dann ist das eine USB-Tastatur oder was?
Ich glaube PS2, ich weiß es nicht genau. Also das Ding ist noch nicht released, das kommt jetzt dann bald. Also daran werkeln die jetzt gerade. Aber wenn man halt die normale Tastatur hernehmen will, die normalen Joysticks und so weiter, dann steckt man das Ding einfach in C64 rein und dann benutzt man davon da die Hardware mit.
Achso, der Fisch. Okay, alles klar.
Und da sind auch noch einen Haufen Sachen schon eingebaut, wie zum Beispiel diese Speeder Cartridges und so was, die halt das Cache-Code bekommen.
Das Ding übernimmt dann aber auch, ist dann sozusagen, übernimmt dann quasi auch diese Maschine. Also da läuft dann sozusagen deren Code auf diesem C64 nur, um das dann diesem emulierten FPGA C64 quasi als Peripherie bereitzustellen.
Ja, es läuft ja auf beiden parallel. Also der C64 lässt das Programm laufen und das Ding eben auch, weil die müssen sich identisch verhalten. Das soll ja eine perfekte Reimplementierung sein. Und wenn du dann den normalen Fernseher anschließt, kriegst du halt da das, was der interne VEC so denkt, wie das Bild gerade ausschauen sollte. Und beim VGA das, was die Reimplementierung macht.
Und dann hat man auch genau das gleiche Bild.
In der Theorie. In der Praxis gibt es aber immer wieder, also so vor zwei Jahren oder so was, hat jemand auch mal wieder irgendein Trick gefunden, irgendwas, was man mit dem VEC machen kann, was man noch gar nicht verstanden hatte, was die Emulatoren alle nicht konnten. Ja, also es geht immer noch. Und weiß ich nicht, weil du vorher gemeint hast, ja da war so eine Pause, da war er mal irgendwann tot. Also 94 wurde er nicht mehr hergestellt, aber die Demoszene war so 95, 96 auch immer noch sehr groß. Und dann, ja so bis 2000, wenn man mal schaut, so welche Demos, wann die Demos rauskamen, die guten Demos, so bis 2000 kamen auch noch gute Demos, dann war lange nichts. Und dann jetzt wieder die letzten paar Jahre, ich glaube, da war so ein bisschen ein Loch drin.
Also der C64 lebt, also zumindest noch nicht tot.
Es gibt auch noch genügend echte, die man immer noch bei Ebay sehr billig kriegen kann. Also es wird zwar nicht mehr hergestellt, aber gut, Klone gibt's, Klone werden auch wieder hergestellt bald, aber auch das Original, man kriegt es sehr einfach.
Also wer Lust hat, sich sozusagen der Plattform noch mal anzunehmen und sie auch zu verstehen, ist ja auch mit einer Menge Reward verbunden. Also wenn man das dann irgendwie einfach gar nicht mehr nur so das Spielen, aber so einfach so dieses Programmieren und dieses komplett Verstehen, das ist definitiv eine lohnenswerte Geschichte vom Lerneffekt her.
Wir wiederholen uns. Vor allem mal auch, das ist jetzt ein neuer Gedanke, mal eine neue Plattform. Weil wer hat denn heutzutage schon eigentlich mal unterschiedliche Plattformen überhaupt noch gesehen? Na gut, in letzter Zeit so mit IOS und so. Jetzt wird ja echt auch zum Computer, aber ich mein so.
Das ist natürlich nicht besonders hackable so.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich mal so andere Ideen, wie eigentlich so ein Computer sich anfühlt, so eine andere Persönlichkeit. Ja, Windows, Mac, Linux, ja, das läuft ja jetzt seit zehn Jahren schon so. Aber jetzt mal so eine ganz andere Art. Da präsentiert einem ein Bildschirm und eine Tastatur. Und jetzt mach mal. Das ist jetzt mal ganz anders. Das hat mich auch immer total fasziniert. Deswegen haben mich auch immer die ganzen Betriebssysteme sehr interessiert. Das macht auch die unterschiedlichen Unixe. Und wie macht eigentlich der Amiga das jetzt?
Ja, Michael, mir gehen jetzt so langsam die Fragen aus. Haben wir denn noch irgendwie einen wichtigen Aspekt jetzt noch vergessen? Starre ich mich schon die ganze Zeit auf dieses Mainboard.
Alle Chips sind mal durch. Ja, also. Da ist noch eine Sicherung drauf. Wenn die weg ist, dann läuft die Uhr nicht mehr. Und der Sit-Chip ist stumm.
Ich glaube, wir haben es. Vielleicht sollten wir noch auf eins hinweisen. Du hast ja auch ein paar, also mit C64 hast du, glaube ich, nur einen Vortrag gehalten auf einem Kongress.
Ja, vor zwei Jahren. Das war auf dem, kann ich zählen, der Bibel, der war es.
Jetzt war gerade 27.
Dann war es 25, genau. 25C3.
Und das waren irgendwie 64 Minuten.
512 Slides.
512 Slides über den C64.
Alles über den C64. Also meine Strategie bei Vorträgen ist ja immer, ich rede doppelt so schnell, wie man es verstehen kann. Und dann muss man sich nachher halt in halber Geschwindigkeit anschauen. VLC und QuickTime können das ganz gut. Also bin ich zu schnell, dann hast du halt einfach den Player zu schnell eingestellt. Und so kriege ich einfach deutlich mehr Informationen rein. Also ich habe da so Feedback gekriegt, ja so 60 Prozent von dem, was du gesagt hast, habe ich verstanden. Aber ja gut, dann spielst du halt in 60 Prozent der Geschwindigkeit ab. Also da habe ich wirklich versucht, alles an Informationen reinzukriegen. Also alles das, was wir jetzt geredet haben, plus noch sehr viel mehr technische Details, weil man eben auch mit so einer Präsentation das sehr optisch anschaulich gestalten kann und dann das besser erklären kann, was genau vorgeht.
Aber das war ja auch nicht der einzige Vortrag, den du so auf dem Kongress gehalten hast. Sondern hat sich ja auch schon anderen Themen zugewendet.
Ich bin ja Wiederholungstäter, genau. Ich habe ja noch jedes Jahr irgendwas gemacht. Was war das alles noch? Auf dem 19. Zentral zum ersten Mal. Da haben wir ein paar andere Leute, weil wir ja, also Xbox Linux war ja unser Projekt. Wir haben ja damals Xbox-Hacking betrieben und dann Linux draufportiert und dann noch ein paar Software exploits und das auch sehr schön verpackt und so. Da haben wir in zwei aufeinander folgenden Jahren über eben Xbox Linux gesprochen. Dann ein Jahr über Gamecube Linux. Da war ich auch mit dabei. Und dann noch mal das Jahr danach, noch mal so ein Abschlussvortrag zu, was hat man jetzt alles aus von diesem Linux-Sicherheitssystem gelernt. Und die Konsolenhacking-Vorträge, die gibt es ja noch bis heute. Das ist ja, das inzwischen haben halt andere Leute übernommen, aber die stehen ja alle irgendwie in Kontakt zu uns. Das ist alles immer noch die selbe Kultur, dieselben Leute im Endeffekt, die sich alle immer noch kennen. Bis halt jetzt den Konsolenhacking-2010-Vortrag, jetzt wo sie die Playstation geknackt haben. Genau, aber gut, damit habe ich jetzt nichts mehr zu tun, nur dass ich halt die Leute kenne. Und ich habe mich jetzt irgendwie mehr dem Retro zugewandt. Ich habe irgendwann mal noch auch auf dem Kongress einen Vortrag über VMware gehalten, wie dann eigentlich Virtualisierung funktioniert, weil es ja auch so eine magische Sache ist. Oder läuft ja nur in das, wie geht denn das eigentlich. Und ja eben jetzt auf dem letzten 27C3 war ja die Interna vom 6502. Wie diese CPU funktioniert, nämlich genau in diese Richtung von Visual 64v2. Wenn man sich das so auf Schaltebene anschaut oder wenn man sich dieses Decode-ROM anschaut, da gibt es so einen Schaltplan, der irgendwo mal geleakt ist. Wir wissen nicht genau, woher er kommt. Das beschreibt schon recht schön, was intern in diesem Ding vorgeht.
So, das kann man sich dann sozusagen auch alles noch mit reinschauen. Gibt ja auch die ganzen Videoaufzeichnungen von den Vorträgen, die sich sozusagen noch mal die Kante geben von dir.
Auf meinem Blog ist es immer alles schön verlinkt, wenn wir auf den mal hinweisen dürfen.
Auf jeden Fall.
pagetable.com. Das bin ich. Da wird auch immer mal wieder schreibe ich, also momentan schreibe ich sehr viel so C64 und Retrograms.
Aber nicht nur.
Nicht nur. Auch so Virtualisierung finde ich auch immer spannend. Alles, was mit Assembler zu tun hat, das ist eigentlich so das Thema. Und was ich auch immer sehr gerne mache, ist so Preservation-Sachen, wie alte Bücher, alte Magazine oder so was mal in vernünftiges Format zu kriegen. Das ziehe ich immer schön durch einen Einzugscanner durch, mache eine PDF draus, die durchsuchbar ist. Also zum Beispiel wer die erste Ausgabe vom 64er-Magazin lesen will, die ist auch von meinem Blog aus verlinkt.
Ja, genau, ja stimmt. Die 64er-Magazine, da gibt es auch ganz viele Archive online. Da kann man sie ja auch noch mal reinlesen. Das ist dann auch wirklich ein Einstieg in die Vergangenheit.
Leider ist das halt nicht besonders vollständig. Also im Endeffekt ist es sehr wenig, was man kriegt vom 64er-Magazin, was sehr schade ist. Genau, da könnte ich ja jetzt mal aufrufen, wenn irgendjemand interessiert ist, wenn irgendjemand einen guten A3-Scanner hat oder interessiert ist mit Photoshop, so ein bisschen mehr oder weniger automatisierte Tasks zu machen oder selbst automatisieren zu können mit sowas wie Photoshop, dann könnte man das kriegen. Also die Magazine aufzutreiben ist ja kein Problem. Ich habe, glaube ich, alle zweimal, damit ich eben sowas machen kann, damit ich das zerlegen kann und vernünftig einen Scanner legen kann. Oder wenn irgendjemand einen A3-Einzugscanner hat, der schön mit 1200 DPI das machen kann, dann kann man wirklich wunderschöne PDFs da wieder draus machen.
Es gibt so automatisierte Buchscanner, die so schön...
Gut, in meiner Wohnung steht halt leider keiner.
Ja, okay, das ist dann ein rein logistisches Prinzip.
Es wäre schon schön, wenn man das alles irgendwie erhalten kann.
Das heißt, du brauchst konkret einen Scanner oder jemanden, dem du das zuschickst oder was?
Jemand, der das scannen kann. Das Scannen ist wirklich das meiste an Arbeit. Ich habe das mal mit einem Flachbett-Scanner probiert, weil ich habe zuerst mal versucht, das zu zerschneiden. In der Mitte zu zerschneiden und dann einzeln zu scannen. Das dauert viel zu lange. Dann in den Einzugscanner schon besser, aber da muss man es halt auch immer noch zerschneiden, weil die immer nur A4 sind. Jetzt habe ich mal einen A3-Flachbett-Scanner. Muss man nicht mehr zerschneiden, aber jede Seite einzeln einlegen. Das ist schon sehr viel Arbeit, wenn man das irgendwie verbessern kann. Ich habe die ganzen Tools und das ganze Know-how, um dann vernünftig schön nachher was draus zu machen, aber es hängt im Endeffekt am Scannen.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Baste-Selbstbau-Buchscanner, die mit einem Glastreieck von oben kommen. Das Buch ist aufgeschlagen und dann kommen so zwei Glasscheiben von oben, die dann so die Seiten links und rechts zur Seite drücken und dann einfach fotografieren.
Ob da dann die genügend Pixel sind?
Ja, die Kameras, die haben heute schon viele Pixel. Aber das wird sich dann alles zeigen. Das soll jetzt aber auch nicht Inhalt der Sendung sein, sondern Inhalt der Sendung war der C64 und was man da alles so entdecken kann und was es so wissenswertes gibt. Das war eine ganze Menge. Ja, und dann beenden wir mal hier die Sendung, war auch lang genug.
Wie lange haben wir es ausgehalten?
So zweieinhalb Stunden waren das jetzt schon und das kann man, das kann auf jeden Fall schon wieder einen Abend gefüllt haben. Aber ihr wollt es ja immer so lange haben, also kriegt ihr es auch so lange. Aber jetzt ist es trotzdem Schluss. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.